this is jocko podcast number 274
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
all right so the last podcast 273 we
were with
anthony herbert tony herbert also known
as and we started off
his journey from a kid growing up in
pennsylvania
so if you haven't listened to podcast
go listen to that right now he tried to
join the marines at 14.
14 years old credit eventually joined
the army at 17 off to the korean war
went from private to master sergeant
all kinds of heroic actions suffered all
kinds of wounds
shot hit with frag white phosphorus
burns
and also bayoneted
multiple times including one bayonet
stab that broke off in his
chest
he in the korean war served as a platoon
leader even though he was just a young
enlisted guy
and eventually at the end of that
podcast and at the end of that part of
his life he was pulled off the
battlefield
one of the most decorated soldiers of
the war sent on a mara
it was basically a morale tour and first
we
got flown back to the to the white house
met president truman
and then basically went to london and
antwerp and brussels and the hague and
all the other european
allies that were fighting alongside
america in
the korean war along the way he met mrs
eleanor roosevelt she encouraged him to
go to college
he kind of agreed one of the quotes he
says in the book is he he agreed because
he was already the youngest master
sergeant in the army and he said what am
i going to do sit around the enlisted
man's club telling stories about korea
so
he was sort of not not over it but he
realized that he had kind of done what
he was going to do
so he ends up getting assigned as an
rotc instructor at a high school in
denver because he liked to ski
uh goes to the third ranger class
that ever happened he was in he ends up
getting married to his hometown
sweetheart mary grace
starts going to college or he then he
gets out of the army
then starts going to college at the
university of pittsburgh while he's
there he writes a book
called conquest to no war nowhere which
was his first book about the korean war
which he later rewrote
which we covered when it was rewritten
was called the making of a soldier
that was podcast 273 for the most part
worked at a steel mill at night while he
was going to college
and then eventually commissioned as an
officer
in the pennsylvania national guard
shout out to the 228 iron soldiers all
right so
so then he goes so then he's back kind
of in the army
and he gets some warnings that the
army's different now
you know the war is over but the good
people got out
we just left with people that shouldn't
even be in the army
that he got those kind of warnings but
he stayed in
he he loves being a soldier he wants to
be a soldier
goes to the basic army infantry course
wins nine out of ten awards
there including the leadership trophy
which
is the leadership trophy is awarded by
the other students like the other
students select who deserves this
leadership trophy then he gets assigned
as a ranger instructor
and he starts he starts
in the mountain phase and so today
we're going to be reading so the first
book that we covered we covered a little
bit so he's written two books
well i guess he's written three one was
conquest of nowhere that one got
rewritten as the making of a soldier
that was the bulk of what we read last
time
this time we're going to read from his
second book primarily
and it's just called soldier just called
soldier
and lots of lessons learned but as i
mentioned in the first
podcast in 273
there's some serious lessons learned
about
life and things get
really crazy when he goes to vietnam as
a battalion commander
and we will get there all right so here
we go
going going to the book soldier written
by
anthony b herbert and he says this
teaching young men the essentials of
mountain climbing combat and survival
was more of a learning experience for me
than for them i began discovering things
about the resources in me
as well as the way the army was moving i
was an alternate instructor at first
assigned to teach cliff descents on
suspension
traverses i took it seriously it was
dangerous business
if you didn't the ropes to be used for
traverses which were one
inch in diameter and 900 feet long cost
the army about 300
each i had set up two of the traverses
on
a 60-foot cliff the day before a new
class was to begin
and that afternoon i went out to inspect
the ropes
one of the criteria for determining the
quality of the kind of rope that was
the present was the presence of a tiny
colored
strand running all the way through its
core i inspected the first
traverse and found the strand but the
second rope
didn't have it which meant that i simply
couldn't approve
its use the strand was an indication
that the machines used to put the hemp
together
into a strong enough cord had worked the
way they were supposed to if the strand
wasn't there
something had gone wrong and the rope
might be faulty
i went back to my quarters and wrote an
unsatisfactory report on the rope
and then went to the chief instructor
and told him of my findings
the army paid good money for that rope
and you want to throw it away he argued
we're not going to do that herbert i
explained what i had found or rather
what i had not found
strand schmann he said you go out there
and test it again
by going down the traverse if it holds
if it holds you it's okay
this is kind of a strange safety check
right go ahead and risk your life to see
if it's going to work
i returned to the cliff and went down
the traverse so he does it
it held it was supposed to be sturdy
enough to support a jeep
i went back and told the captain and he
ordered me conduct the class the next
day using the rope
i filed the unsatisfactory report and
went to bed
the next morning as we stood at the top
of the cliff i ordered the class into
two lines the captain nodded his
approval from nearby
one group would use the traverse made of
the rope i'd inspected and approved
the other would be would use the
traverse of the rope i'd inspected and
rejected
a young corporal in the second group
stepped off
the rope snapped and he fell 60 feet to
the rocks below
i went down quickly on the other
traverse his body was so broken it
almost crumbled in my hands as i lifted
him into a jeep and sent him to the
hospital
the captain had seen what happened he
left the scene
running up over the hill the students
were nervous they said
they weren't going through with it i
made them a little speech on courage and
reminded
them that they'd all known that ranger
training included risks
it seemed to work we spent the rest of
the morning learning how to use the
traverse
there were no further accidents and at
lunch time i went back to base
where colonel byerly and the captain
asked me how the kid who fell was going
to be he'll be dead on arrival i said
don't say that the captain said you
can't say that how the hell do you know
because i'm the one who put him on on
that jeep for the hospital
he'll be dead on arrival
the phone rang it was a hospital calling
and the captain came back to barely and
me
with a strange look on his face the
hospital says he was dead on arrival he
reported
it was quiet in the office finally the
captain said
i was responsible for the accident
i realized that sir and i'll stand
whatever comes from it i said
you're responsible you know he said
you're the one who's responsible
i know sir i know i answered
so i'm sure it's pretty obvious why i
decided to um pull out that
particular quote because
that is 100 accurate
obviously he's taking ownership for what
happened but it's not just
lip service if you don't think something
is right and you execute it it's on you
it's on you
a little bit more from ranger school
and this book look this book is
four almost 500 pages long and obviously
i'm not reading the whole thing there is
so much good information
and i'm just i tried to parse it down to
some
key points along the way but this is a
this is a book that is packed filled
with knowledge and i try and bring out
as much of that as i could
some of the war stories that i don't
even go into there's there's
all kinds of combat scenarios that i
don't even go into
just an incredible book um fast forward
a little bit here
i didn't develop any really
sophisticated theories about teaching
and i still haven't
what seemed to be important was that the
teacher know what he was talking about
and be able to
show as well as tell one of the
fallacies in army training these days
is that kind of experience is no longer
part of the tradition kids are taught
combat techniques by men who
through no fault of their own of course
have never spent a moment in combat and
we wonder
how it is that we turn out soldiers like
cali
talking about lieutenant cali mila
massacre
what seemed most important then and
still does
was that the students realize that the
army and war are not really
games at all even though they might seem
that way at times especially when you
hear someone
of the bar room tales or when you hear
some of the bar room tales of
the way it was at incheon or that night
in the mekong delta
i saw so many army teachers who were
trying to make up for the times
when they had been down at the bottom of
the heap when they had been the ones
taking orders
they played games with their men
building their egos with
nip nitpicking orders that produce
nothing but dissent
and rancor among the men
so often i found it that way in the
military the rules and the regs
and the juvenile cover-ups and the
children's games
it had nothing to do with creating a
system of discipline or building
soldiers
it was simply an ego game
again i think it's quite obvious why why
why i
you know i'm talking about this this is
something that we all have to watch out
for
you get put in that position of
authority you gotta watch out
you gotta watch out it's a good good
opportunity for you to
pump up your ego make them do some
stupid stuff that doesn't make any sense
and we'll do that all day long if you
let your ego run the show
that's what you're doing and by the way
it creates what do you say
dissent amongst the troops
all right so what he does in the next
kind of stages of the books
he gets stationed in germany he kind of
creates this
provisional ranger platoon he becomes
the commander of the provisional ranger
platoon
1962 he gets promoted to captain he's
deployed to africa he's deployed
to well the congo in africa puerto rico
dominican republic
the persian gulf deployed to bahrain all
in the 60s
and there's all kinds of good stories in
the book about
these different situations that he's in
he's doing some kind of clandestine type
operations
he's it's just just a you know
borderline spy
scenarios going down working with the
cia
enter interacting with the cia
intelligence services
and this kind of stuff so he does all
that
1966 goes back to being a ranger
instructor
starts working towards his master's
degree in psychology gets his degree in
1968 he gets offered a slot at war
college
but of course he doesn't want to go to
war college not yet anyways he wants to
go to vietnam
and the bunch of reasons obviously he he
has always felt that he
wants to be a combat leader
and he sees an opportunity to to lead
he also has never worked with
helicopters at the level they were used
in vietnam
so well so he he said quote i wanted to
know i wanted to go i wanted to see i
wanted to fight
ask his chain of command hey can i
please go to vietnam
and he does he ends up getting orders to
vietnam he wants to be a battalion
commander because by this time he's been
promoted a few more times
he wants to be a battalion commander he
but he doesn't show up immediately
in vietnam as a battalion commander he
has to pay his dues first
and the way he pays his dues is by
becoming the
inspector general of the 173rd airborne
brigade so inspector general
what's an inspector general the
inspector general
their mission the inspector general
mission is to quote provide
impartial objective and unbiased advice
and oversight to the army through
relevant timely
and thorough inspections and assistance
investigations
and training to promote and enable
stewardship accountability integrity
and efficiency
also good order and discipline and
enhanced total army
readiness that's what an ig have you
ever heard that term before
ig inspector general yes you have yeah
where did you hear it
what movie
uh it i don't remember it might have
been like mash or something like this
okay okay i was trying to think of a
good way to explain
all those things and have you ever seen
police movies where they have the
internal affairs oh yeah that's kind of
i think that's a good
comparison right it's somebody that's
kind of inspecting
us like our team yeah right it's not
it's not hey we're out inspecting
looking what the bad guys are doing
we're looking at what we're doing as
good guys we're making sure we're doing
the right things
internal affairs they came off as
kind of like that wasn't a good thing
when internal affairs is involved it's
kind of like they're investigating some
some some bad yeah something went
something bad happened
yeah inspector general comes i don't
know it just hits me as something more
like hey we're
almost like a compliance officer like
kind of like hey
just to make sure everyone's kind of
doing the right thing
it's not like it seems like they're kind
of on your side
still okay no well
let me phrase that if you're doing the
right things they're on your side if
you're doing the wrong things
just like internal affairs if you were
doing all the right things and internal
affairs came along you'd be like oh cool
they're here to keep people straight
if you were if you were a criminal or
you were if you were
if you were corrupt right well a
training day
your favorite movie yes sir but train is
there is there
internal affairs and training day no so
there should have been
right you got there so there should have
been someone tracking hey
what's going on where's this money going
where's this
you know what where are these reports
why aren't they yeah like in the whole
scenario for sure but
probably not in the movie for giving
that particular storyline but
yeah yeah overall for sure yeah that's
that guy
what's denzel washington's character
name in that movie do you know
alonzo okay alonso would be not a big
fan of internal affairs
no sir although he was he was
such a mover and so manipulative he
might have had some internal affairs
people that were on his side
yeah he kind of did imply that not
internal affairs necessarily but kind of
like he had some people on the inside
kind of backing his moves when they're
talking about getting drug tested and
stuff
there you go there you go so so that's
what that's what the ig is
and look you know i was in the navy for
20 years obviously i saw some ig
inspections go down or the ig would get
called in
like maybe someone's uh uh some
some ammunition goes missing for an
extent
it's not the kind of thing where
something happens one time and you know
the command would just kind of handle
that
but if there's some kind of an ongoing
problem yeah
the i maybe someone's falsifying travel
claims
or something like that okay so bring in
the ig
who's gonna give an unbiased look
because
you know maybe the commander's wrapped
up in it or whatever yeah
so okay so they're not just sort of
around all the time or nothing like that
you can call them
specifically okay and the other the
other place they could get used is let's
say you work for me and i'm a tyrannical
jerk you could you could then reach out
to the ig
check so you could reach out to the ig
sort of through a anonymous
you know yeah that means uh uh email or
something and say hey
this guy jocko is verbally
and physically abusive that's a good tip
to to his subordinates so there you go
so this guy shows up as the ig now now
like you said it seems like they would
be on our side right
yeah that was my misinterpretation
though i thought inspector general sort
of like just
another guy who's there or another
department kind of that's there
all the time that's kind of like oh hey
by the way guys you guys are kind of
slacking over here so let's tighten that
up we're all good kind of a thing
so if you were doing the right things
for the right reasons you'd have no
reason to fear the ig
but if you were doing some things that
were shady
you might you might not be very
welcoming or you might be scared of them
and the ig is obviously it's a weird
role to play right because
you're looking at your team and you're
sort of
you can end up in a situation where
you're accusing your team
of doing things that are wrong so it's a
weird dynamic
and so he shows up as the ig
for this brigade and
and this is the thing about anthony
herbert
he seems
like a very
what's the word here he's like a
straight shooter
right a straight shooter that a little
bit of black and white a little bit of
like hey right and wrong
good or bad good or evil he seems like
he's got
that kind of a personality and
and actually you can go watch some of
his interviews there's interviews of him
on youtube and you can see some of them
but you're gonna start to see that and
that's sort of in the first one that we
when i did cover the beginning of this
book just to talk about his upbringing
you know he's a church-going guy he's
so he's a he's kind of
he's kind of a he's very straightforward
and right or wrong that's what the
personality
comes across for the most part to me
and so this ig
you know he's gonna kind of he kind of
comes out of the gate swinging
he kind of comes out of the gate
swinging and here we go he's checking in
to this guy
he's checking in with this guy who's uh
who's the lieutenant colonel
who they call the mayor of on k you know
some
some outpost over there in vietnam the
guy is the commander of the brigade
support battalion so he's checking in
and the guy's saying you know i can get
you this i can get you that but then he
says i
i expect some cooperation from you in
return
he added like what i asked well like
talking things over before they go to
the general
he replied most things never even have
to reach his ears if you and i cooperate
you know herbert
sort of run things ourselves trust each
other get along
and keep it all in the family you see
where this is going
i stared at him and said he had to be
joking i realized
almost instantly he was not i'm supposed
to be
an ig i said he seemed not to have heard
launching instead into a lengthy
recitation of his immense
responsibilities as the man in charge of
the barrack the brigade's rear
area headquarters everything at on k was
under his purview he said
men slept where he told them to sleep
and took their meal wherever he assigned
them
and enjoyed themselves in his clubs and
theaters
and bought from his post exchange
it suddenly dawned on me that here was a
senior lieutenant colonel
supposedly a professional soldier who
was bragging about his job as a building
officer
a task generally reserved for a second
lieutenant in the states
and usually for a not too keen second
lieutenant at that he rambled on and on
about the scope of his
influence and i tried hard to look
interested and concerned
finally he stopped it was my turn look
colonel
i i understand your position and if
you'll just assign me a room and a mess
i'll be glad to cooperate
i said he smiled and relaxed in his
chair but you have to understand my
position too i added
now he was staring i'm an ig
so i work for the commander who by the
way is general allen
not you since i work for the general
i'll report to the general and if that
isn't a satisfactory remain
arrangement for you well then you can
talk it over with the general maybe the
two of you can work something out more
suitable
his jawline straighten noticeably in the
meantime if you're finished i have a lot
of work to do
i concluded he looked ill is there
anything wrong i asked rising from the
bed
no not at all he said rather glumly also
rising i have some things to do myself
i nodded open the door to the outer
roman and he left
the place was quiet until the sergeant
spoke you just made an enemy sir
he said from his desk a real dangerous
enemy i walked into the outer room
real dangerous real dangerous sir real
real dangerous i repeat
repeated smiling slightly yes sir
he he's okay sir he said sheepishly when
he noticed my grin
no kidding sir he's really bad news i
took some papers
from his desk and looked at him so am i
sarge i asked
i said and i'm not kidding either
you see where this is going right so
you can see where this is going he's go
he's forming an antagonistic
relationship with a guy right out of the
gate
and you know i i talked about this on ef
online the other day
we we you know we talk about take the
high ground to the high ground will take
you
but when you're on the high ground you
have to be careful
that you don't
that you don't launch
attacks on other people from a position
where you feel like you're superior to
everybody else
you are in a superior position this is
known right you when you're on the high
ground you're in a superior position
but let me tell you this when you start
to launch attacks with the attitude that
you're superior
you're giving up some of the high ground
so and this is what's really what's
really a a hard line to walk in this
book
and as i try and talk through this i'm
not going to do a good job of it
but just because you're right
doesn't mean you're right right and
you're gonna see this over and over
again i mean this guy is
a like morally at least he appears to be
and again there's some controversy
around us everything we're talking about
he certainly appears if you read the
words that he writes in this book
he certainly appears to be a morally
upstanding
human being that and look at what he did
look at his heroic actions from the last
last podcast what he did in the korean
war this guy is willing to sacrifice
for his brothers in arms he's
an incredible soldier and you're going
to see how much his men
how much his men loved and revered him
which is awesome
but he's on that high ground and he's
this is this is this is what he's doing
he's on the high ground and he's looking
down on others from the high ground
and when you do that they don't like it
people don't like it doesn't feel good
yeah
yeah that's interesting what you wha
what did you
how did you just put it like you just
because you're right doesn't mean you're
right or whatever
you're right doesn't mean you're right
yeah there's got to be a better way to
say that it's like just because you're
right
doesn't mean you should smack people in
if it doesn't mean other people are
going to think that you're right
yeah um just because you're right
doesn't mean you're right or
what you said actually does sound kind
of cool i feel like that should be the
quote
uh i used to like get into little
debates whatever with my brother i think
i told you this before
where you know how he is he's the kind
where
there's no like we understand getting in
debates with your brother yeah yeah he's
down for the cause and he goes hard
but um anyway so we do
we'd get into these things you know
sometimes against my will or whatever
and
so finally i came to the conclusion that
i said hey what you're saying is like
right
is right but what you're doing is wrong
yeah like i see what you're saying
you're saying all the correct stuff
there's all true stuff it's all factual
and all this stuff but what you're doing
right now is wrong like you can't like
force people into debates you can't like
so it's kind of the same concept
essentially you know where it's like
yeah this guy is taking that he's doing
the right thing
you know he's he's right he's doing the
right thing but what you're doing kind
of right now in a big and essentially in
a bigger picture there's just a bigger
picture in play yep
and look there's a there's things that
are
universally morally wrong so there are
things like
that well almost universally morally
wrong there's things that
you can say that that is not
correct that is not right that should
not happen
when he starts he's getting into some of
this stuff early on
look you you're right
colonel herbert you're right but you're
you're not gonna make this easy
and if you and if you if you run around
just slapping people from the high
ground
what you're doing is you're you're
you're you have to get off the high
ground
to slap people you're coming down off
the high ground to slap people
and well we're gonna see how this
unfolds
fast forward a little bit within a few
weeks i realized that the desk sergeant
had been worth listening to
he had it pegged pound for pound the
brigade was garbage discipline was lax
the troops were slovenly disrespectful
and sluggish
meant mentally as well as physically it
was obvious that on k
it was obvious that in anke at least
there were no match for either the
vietcong or the
north vietnamese regulars as the
sergeant had said they preferred pot
two to one but marijuana was only an
expression of deeper more serious
failure
at on k the troops wore what they damn
well wanted to wear
including beads and bracelets they
capped their teeth with different colors
red blue and gold
and they called the hierarchy
[ __ ] and printed [ __ ] the green
machine on their jackets and hats
some of them wore earrings a few sported
nose rings
and the battle flag of the confederacy
flew for many of the bunkers
the sergeant was right about nobody
giving a damn too
almost everyone looked the other way on
k was a staff in headquarters post
crammed with chairborne commando types
in every in any other war it would have
been ridiculous but not in vietnam
every careerist who could weedle his way
was over there drawing combat pay while
the citizens back home were getting bled
for the bill
the troops knew best what to call it a
humbug
the 173rd was the largest brigade in
vietnam
with over 10 000 men attached to it it
was according to the manual
a combat brigade with absolutely no dead
weight
but it was a humbug there were five
so-called combat battalions in the
brigade and not
one of them had more than 600 physically
present for duty
out of a total of 10 000 men there were
no more than 3
000 at the battalion level which means
that some seven thousand
were assigned to support roles
steakhouses pizza huts
clubs headquarters the generals mess
artillery
engineers etc even a pro even among the
approximately
3 000 at the combat battalion level not
all were looking
not all were out looking with their
rifles some were of course
but the battalions had their own rear
areas just like the brigade with their
own steakhouses and their own clubs
each battalion was composed of five
companies one of them a makeshift
out outfit responsible for heavy weapons
which left four companies for walking no
company in the battalion brigade
had more than 75 men physically present
and ready to go
thus each battalion fielded about 300
combat troopers
except that each battalion assigned one
company to guard its base of operations
each day
that left a maximum of 225 men available
for the field
or 1125 on the brigade basis
and that would have been on a good day
with everybody out and
everybody with a rifle but everybody
didn't carry a rifle
some toted radios some stayed back and
typed
some worked in company supply some were
fireflies the daily helicopter resupply
lifts
and some were just plain screwed off so
on an
average day the 173rd airborne brigade
could feel a field approximately 800 men
if all of its battalions were out in the
year i was in the brigade all the
battalions were never
out simultaneously we field less than
800 out of 10
000 troops in the brigade on a
countrywide basis it meant that out of
500 000 men
we had there at the peak of our
involvement less than 50 000 were
engaged in the business of fighting in
the field
and that figure applies only if all the
other outfits were doing as well as the
173rd as general westmoreland like to
say the 173rd was the cream of the whole
crop
it wasn't that our kids didn't fight
well in the field it was just that so
damn few of them ever got there we had a
500 000 man army
fielding less than one infantry division
and did in world war
ii or in korea on paper we were hell on
wheels
the reports had a column for it in the
field
and on paper it was 98 or more
every day i've filed those reports
myself and they look truly magnificent
all the guys at the steakhouse in the
field all the guys at the club
in the field the general's orderlies in
the field the lifeguards at esther
williams swimming pool
in the field stunning absolutely
stunning
and from the and from time to time i
found myself inclined to go along with
it
it was so mesmerizing that when i later
took over a battalion myself
i added another column to my reporting
procedure just to keep things straight
ass in the grass i called the new column
it was no joke
it was necessary and as in the grass
means you're actually
in the field
you can see this guy he's going hard in
the paint
and again
i'm reading from the book i'm not these
i don't i
they're we're going to get to sort of
some of the pushback against this stuff
but we have to we have to take him for
what he's saying
well we have to let me rephrase that we
have to listen to what he's saying
he goes on here i soon discovered that
almost all the problems at any level
of the brigade were either the direct or
indirect result of piss-poor leadership
being an ig so you got he's got this
attitude
and he's the ig oh is he going to be
making friends what's your prediction
being in ig was an extremely educational
experience i was spending about
20 nights a month with ass in the grass
troops
blending as well as i could taking every
opportunity afforded
afforded me to discuss tactics i found
that one of the best ways to get to know
any particular outfit was to accompany
its men
on an ambush generally they were a
disgrace so this is interesting
i i guarantee and i don't you know i
don't use that word very often
he shows up as the ig and what does he
do he starts going in the field all the
time with the troops
because he's that kind of bro you know
he's that kind of brother that's just
like oh
i'm in the army we got troops i'm going
in the field
so that's what he starts doing and as
he's going out on patrol
well this is what he finds the fault was
obvious poor leadership and more
specific
absentee leadership few of the ambush
patrols i accompanied included a senior
or non-commissioned
officer the enlisted men had humped all
day long and carried their load
and then at night they were expected to
stay awake and cut it again the next day
they took their sleep where and when
they could get it on patrol
and for what most and for the most part
the company commanders didn't know what
the hell was going on or worse just
didn't care
it was their fault but the real culprits
were at the higher level battalion
commanders who wrote out the procedures
almost verbatim from the fort benning
operations and training handbook
passed them down to their subordinates
and let it go at that
they were covered the procedures had no
relationship
to the realities of combat
and you got to remember the the colonel
that originally told me about this book
this guy is this the same kind of vain
as hackworth
he's coming at you and he loves
being a soldier and he loves his
soldiers but he's got no love he's got
no love for the upper chain of command
you can
as you can see uh field standards which
apply to combat
conditions are important and those were
the criteria i applied as i walked
through b
companies area and then he's getting
into like actually being out there a
good soldier wears even the most ragged
gear well
even in the field he is trim neat and
tight with
pockets buttoned and no loose or hanging
straps or webbing he does not wear
sunglasses he keeps a clean face and
clean weapon and clean ammunition
these kids didn't cut it the reason i
could only conclude was poor leadership
leadership's most important thing on the
battlefield
good or bad it was strictly a matter of
leadership he's talking about going on
patrol with a couple different
um companies take the contrast i found
between b
company and c company it was the same
battalion same area of operations with
approximately the same number of troops
in the same kind of mission
yet while b company was a mess c company
was strack
strategic tough and ready around the
clock
they were airborne man all the way one
night i went along on a platoon sized
patrol commanded by a young lieutenant
it was like clockwork like beautiful
swiss clockwork
we moved quietly paused for a silent sea
wrap meal and drifted off further into
the brush to set up shop nobody smoked
nobody talked charlie company and its
lieutenant webster
were hunters and as i sat tight against
a palm tree that night i felt good about
being out there with them
they had a purpose just before dawn
webster received orders
this is such a good lesson just before
dawn webster received orders
to drift back to base about 12 miles
away
helicopters were unavailable he was told
so orders were to foot it back and bring
along
the mermites the thermal food containers
that weighed about 30 pounds of where
clumsy as hell to carry
webster stared at me in the early
morning light
it's stupid he said but it's an order i
replied playing it straight
he looked at me steadily and then made
up his mind yeah he said
well [ __ ] them we're not carrying no
goddamn cans back through the bush
he turned to his radio man pass the word
to get rid of the garbage cans and all
we're going to take a hike so keep it
light and don't leave anything for
charlie
the radio man turned to leave and
webster stopped him with a hand on his
shoulder
the first [ __ ] noise somebody gets it
in the mouth he warned and then turned
to me
i'll take the gig and the ass chewing
webster had a real outfit because he was
a real leader he had a good reputation
and he earned an even larger one by the
time we left
the captain and b company and webster
and c company
both had the same raw material yet one
was running a sloppy sad ass show that
couldn't cut it
the other was commanding a tough tight
combat ready
and combat able outfit the difference
was leadership so there you go
that's a freaking classic case of you
get told to do something stupid
what's the good leader do now he could
have had that argument maybe said like
hey you really want me to carry this
stuff
that's just a big pain in the ass and he
says you know what there's a colonel
here
[ __ ] it we're not doing that that
doesn't make sense
he says this if a legitimate study is
made of that war most americans will be
stunned to learn that we killed a hell
of a lot of our own people once again a
failure directly traceable to poor
leadership
all it took was the sound of a booby
trap or the sighting of movement and we
were prone to just open up to fire to
the jungle and brush
in every direction without any idea of
who might be
on the right or left or behind or ahead
we did it over and over again
to ourselves
here's an example he gives once again we
had killed one of our own in this
particular case
he had caused his own death it was said
he was a young lieutenant
out on his first patrol according to the
report he had set up the ambush
and then left its perimeter to establish
security which was completely asked
backwards
but nevertheless the way he had been
trained
by the us army
when i was in ranger school at fort
benning i had seen the example set
dozens of times
without any criticism training [ __ ]
we had too many damn academics we
trained not only with blank ammunition
but with blank
attitudes as well using instructors who
had gone through the same kind of blank
training
men who in their wildest dreams could
not relate to a real combat patrol
because it had never been part of their
own experience the army claimed the
instructors were combat veterans and
some no doubt were
but most had merely been in combat zones
because of that kind of training the
young lieutenant was dead
the report detailed how he had gone out
from the patrol's main body
to position the outpost people himself
just as he had been taught and then
headed back through the deep jungle
and at night alone toward his main group
in the daylight moving through brush is
hard at night
it's a formidable task when his men
heard movement to their rear
the report related they called him on
the the radio
at least he had enough sense to take it
along so they got an ambush set up
he goes to set some security out now
he's walking back
and the guys that are in the ambush hear
noise
so they call them up and say hey you
know we hear noise behind us
and what does the lieutenant say he says
cream and they did
he was dropped in his tracks schooled
trained ranger airborne and he had
ordered his own
execution i tried to console myself
by thinking that anybody so goddamn
ignorant deserved to die but it didn't
work
i knew he had been trained by guys like
me
not me personally but by senior
personnel like me
it was our fault
i tried to imagine myself doing what he
had done even several years earlier and
i couldn't
he was worse than untrained he was badly
trained
he had no business being out there in
charge on his first patrol
and his battalion commander couldn't be
held blameless either it was sickening
we were the healthiest wealthiest
supposedly best trained soldiers in the
world
our army had the finest raw material of
any country
we had the equipment and the experience
to do better we fought like a bunch of
amateurs
i shoved my coffee aside and looked
around the talk
there were white cloths and flowers on
the tables and paintings on the walls it
was ludicrous
i grabbed a chopper back to on k and on
the way
constructed the rest of the nights that
night's pitiful drama
the dead lieutenant was from a little
town in pennsylvania
not far from where i had grown up a
telegram would soon arrive
and the middle-aged mother would
collapse on the couch in the living room
while the father tried to console her
through his own tears
i imagine myself walking into the room
and standing at the end of the couch
looking down on them and saying that i
had killed their kid
the vision passed and i was grateful
that he wasn't one of my men
and i wouldn't have to explain it even
to myself
we had much much too much whatever the
reason was
the nature of war the difference in the
attitudes of the personnel the abundance
was overwhelming
the red cross for instance came up with
15 000
individual christmas packages for the 10
000 men
of the 173rd he's kind of going on a
rant here about
just what that giant logistical
and rear echelon footprint was like
sergeant ren
the motel they have a motel the motel
manager
told me and booth that the tab for the
brigade's entertainment
ran close to thousand dollars a month so
there's
all this stuff is going on and and look
i'm
he he accounts for a lot of the stuff
that he's investigating with the ig
there's
stealing going on there's fraud going on
there's rape going on sexual harassment
and sexual assaults and murder and
prisoner abuse
people going awol there's all kinds of
criminal behavior happening
he goes into this one uh the records of
the steakhouse and
pizza hut were equally shocking tons of
meat were unaccounted for along with
thousands of pre-fixed pizzas and
truckloads of liquor and beer
three years later congress would be
pulling the covers off what would become
known as the club scandals
it would involve generals at the very
top and the very top
sergeant of the whole army sergeant
major woolridge
whom general westmoreland himself had
hand-picked
as the u.s army's first top kick even
then the army would be trying to sweep
it under the rug
it was in our brigade that the
investigation which led to the scandal
started our investigation
launched at general allen's request the
lines were being drawn and the ig
shop was no longer sloughed off in
dinner conversations
it'd become a power and i had become for
some of my comrades in arms
the enemy
fast forward a little bit he's looking
he's remember he went there as the ig
but he's supposed to get a battalion and
become a battalion commander eventually
it would be the third battalion and i
would get it in april he said
this would necessitate an extension of
my tour so i could get in my six-month
minimum of command
time but it would be worth the extension
he said
the present commander of the third
battalion would have six months in by
april which was
another anomaly of the vietnam war it
mattered not that a commander was doing
a great job or a crappy job
six months was the magic number officers
got their tickets punched in six months
and then got the hell out to some other
assignment to work on another credit or
get
their another coupon certified general
westmoreland
had said it a long time before when i
was a major that the russians were very
envious of the way our officer corps was
getting tremendous combat experience in
vietnam
and even then i knew it was [ __ ] it
takes a commander a couple months to
become acclimated to his responsibility
a couple more to get going and then he's
gone it was crazy besides
we were losing in vietnam a fact which
the us army officers corps
seemed not to want to recognize it would
have been better to have fought the
whole goddamn war with a hundred
honest-to-god commanders than a thousand
of the half-assed combat leader types we
were producing
whatever gave the notion we could build
a better mousetrap in six months
it was a pipe dream and what was worse
was that the leaders
quote the the quote leaders we were
grinding out
would be not an asset but a detriment in
a big war
should one come then they would be
considered
experts and the delusion would cost us
plenty
so you go there your battalion commander
for six months
you get you get your box checked and
then you're out and by the way now all
of a sudden you're
you're a battalion commander so that
means what you say is gold
another thing he's got to deal with
fragging
fragging the deliberate attack on a
non-com or an
officer by an enlisted man or men was
not unknown in the 173rd
one sergeant over in the signal section
had made the mistake of raising hell
with a trooper about the cleanliness of
his area
the man wired a claymore mine outside
the sergeant's room
aimed it right through the wall of the
switch at the switchboard
went to a phone and called his victim
sergeant lost both legs there was a
fragging in 2nd battalion 2
with seven wounded they tried to get
nicholson with explosives
and on another occasion they tried to
blow up his tactical operation center
one of the men in 2nd battalion had
reportedly blown himself to bits with a
claymore mine but my investigation
failed to corroborate this it had been
in his hands
so here's a guy with a claymore mine in
his hands that was certain
but there were two men in the nearby
bunker handling the
handling the controls of the mine when
it went off the victim had left the
bunker to retrieve the mine at the
request of the other two
and somehow they said the circuit had
been completed
i wasn't a real detective but even
though even though two company
commanders swore it was accidental
i did sign my report with a
recommendation that the
criminal investigate investigation
division check into it
they never did
4th battalion had a genuine insurrection
herb matsuo the executive the battalion
executive officer told me
an old colonel living in an
air-conditioned trailer had become
sort of a father figure for the riff
raff and the battalion
no kidding tourney tony herb said he's
actually pulled all the freaks in around
him and made a personal
bodyguard outfit with weapons and all
and the old geezer is dumb enough to
believe they're responding to him
the colonel called his men the mafioso
they're going to cause serious trouble
tony they're the worst kind of people we
have over here they're killers and i'm
not joking you better get word to
general allen before it's too late
um uh i think i might be kind of
confused so fragging
is what fragging is a term
where it's it's um what it means is
you got an officer or you got a senior
enlisted person that you don't like
mm-hmm and you kill them okay so that's
a thing
that's a dead there you go there's two
examples damn okay uh
they put it in movies in platoon you've
seen platoon right no
what i know here's the guy i know
are you serious i am serious i have
never seen platoon
okay well go assignment go watch platoon
yeah okay so okay okay it's in movies
uh yeah there's a lot of things in
movies but it's scene that seems really
weird obviously that doesn't happen
nowadays well you certainly hope not
yeah
i mean i've i've never heard of a
creative case of fragging now but yes in
vietnam
it absolutely like there's there you go
there's cases of it right there
so so imagine this you are a young
21 year old 19 year old 18 year old
person
you don't believe in this war you don't
like it you don't want to die
and in comes you know lieutenant rambo
that's like we're going to go out we're
going to take the fight to the enemy and
you think you can get killed
yeah and he's going to charge you with
being a coward or whatever
you're killing people that's what's
happening over there so you're going out
on a combat operation you get into a
firefight
oh lieutenant young lieutenant happens
to get shot
yeah i guess on training day technically
that's what he did
or was trying to do where it's like yeah
you know we're gonna see if this guy's
gonna play ball with us
in our in our group he doesn't
and then he sets him up to get killed
yeah that's a
well yeah that's a fragging it tries to
anyway
yeah it's a real thing it's a real thing
um there's another he's doing an
investigation
of a company that got creamed he said
so this company like took massive
casualties
and he's talking through it what had
happened
with uh he's about to talk through with
general allen
it had been marijuana i took it back to
allen and he didn't like it one bit
the company had been creamed and there
wasn't a single dead enemy
i suggested that we write it up as a
lesson learned one that
even a nitwit trooper could understand
no one individual had been at fault i
reasoned it had been marijuana
and as bad as that was it would serve as
a valuable purpose it would serve a
valuable purpose as a combat lesson for
the living
marijuana and guns don't miss mix
the general was staring at me when i
finished you must be mad
i said sir do you realize what you're
asking he said
walking over to his window for another
glance at those goddamn flowers
he this guy had flowers like panda
planted outside of his window
can you imagine what you've just
suggested those were american kids two
captains and a hell of a lot of american
kids are dead
he threw up his hands in disgust and sat
down at his desk
and you want me to tell higher
headquarters and their families
that they were on dope not dope sir
marijuana
and we don't have to say that everyone
was on it just point out that the reason
that
they had left that that was the reason
they had had their asses creamed
he stood up again i'll have to think
about it for the time being just keep it
to yourself understand
i stood up i understand sir he sat back
down again and i will consider it
later i read about a company's fate in
the stars and stripes and in our own
brigade newspaper
the sky soldier the two accounts were
nearly identical
the company had put up one hell of a
fight but had been overrun by a
numerically superior force
at a substantial cost to the enemy it
was one more glorious chapter in the
glorious history of the 173rd airborne
brigade
the official accounts of that night on
the hill were a goddamn discredit to
every mother's son who fought worth a
lick in vietnam
the general no doubt believed it saved
some face
i never mentioned it again
so you know you get like this is about
mass cover-ups
right and no lessons learned by the way
so that lesson learned doesn't get
passed on anybody
the story of a company's heroism in
gallantry was published about the same
day that lieutenant colonel joseph
ross franklin joined the brigade as a
replacement
as the deputy commander franklin had
graduated from west point in 1949
won a distinguished service cross in
korea his head was completely hairless
he shaved it
he looked like a badass combat commander
he was impressive no doubt and his teeth
sparkled they say he's a breath of fresh
air abbott remarked
so here comes this guy franklin
and i think he's the most
decorated officer from his class
at west point this guy franklin
and that's from korea
and so you think you know if if you were
a decorated highly decorated veteran
from korea and i was a decorated highly
decorated veteran from korea there's a
good chance that you and i could meet
and be like hey
bro right on right like we could just be
you know have this kind of unified past
right sure
what else could happen to you a little
bit threatened some competition
we should have some ego scenarios right
we could have that competition between
you and me
and i think i'm a little bit braver than
you my my medals are a little bit
you know matt whatever yeah well
unfortunately that was the d it ain't it
ain't going to be brewing out yeah
um here we go
how about a briefing he finally
suggested and don't pull any punches
herbert
i finished he had one question we're
that bad huh we're worse sir but you'll
see it for yourself
and it's not because the caliber of the
troops either we have the finest
top sergeants i have ever known in the
army and we have the healthy
healthiest toughest privates you can
find anywhere
but the worst general he said not really
i said
allen is okay then leadership sir
i said and then he not then as he nodded
i related every last error i'd seen in
the brigade
when i finished i attributed them all
directly to lack of leadership
how do you mean that herbert franklin
asked
it was precisely what i wanted him to
ask
the troops are ragged ass because they
have no one to emulate that they respect
men are dying because leaders don't care
enough to lead it isn't allen in
particular although he's included
but the real problem is at a much lower
level at the level of the battalions and
the companies
if i followed regulations i'd be
recommending quartz marshall for every
last battalion commander i've seen in
this brigade
and i've seen them all they write policy
books
have their men initial them and then try
and correct any value
violations they after they occur nobody
leads by example
they command from 1500 feet up in a
chopper then
and they wear spit shine boots like
they're on parade while their men
hump through the bush with their asses
half out of their trousers
everybody plans big but nobody sees to
it but they're
that their plans are carried out our
lieutenant colonels fight their
battalions on paper as if they were
chess pieces on a board
that's herbert the office was definitely
quiet until he spoke
what do you recommend herbert well
since you asked kick a couple battalion
commanders in the ass
get them out of their birds and onto the
ground make them spend a few nights
out with their units and don't permit
them the right to transfer the men they
consider bad news force them to get off
their asses and lead
and then we'll have a brigade that's
exactly why why i'm here herbert he said
sir to lead he said that's why the
brigade is getting a new general to lead
general piers is damn sick of
allen and his entire hodgepodge he
walked to the door
things are about to change herbert for
the better he stepped out into the
darkness
i slipped the files back in the cabinet
and sat down for a moment to think about
it
maybe he was going to make a difference
i'm used maybe as abbott had told me
franklin would be a breath of fresh air
so
off to a good start we'll do a little
bit of brewing out
uh then we have brigadier general john w
barnes took over the 173rd thus making a
complete change command
that as abbott had said was supposed to
be bring a breath of fresh air
to that part of vietnam
[Applause]
so then things start to go sideways
there's a little incident that goes down
the next day i was summoned to lz
english by franklin the new deputy
commander the brigade
you're a no good disloyal son of a [ __ ]
he said for openers
what are you talking about i asked you
insulted one of my battalion commanders
one of your battalion commanders i
repeated yes god damn it one of mine
no sense in trying to lie out of it
either because your ass is going to
swing
i was dumbfounded until he finally
explained that he had heard about the
call from northington to general allen
and northington said you suggested that
call franklin said
you did it without permission what do
you think i should have done i asked
come to me
that's what for what reason because i'm
the commander that's why he said
and all along i thought general barnes
was the new top man in the brigade my
eyes were wide but i tried to keep the
emotion
out of my voice i knew damn well i was
treading on very thin ice
you sir are not my commander the general
is
you can you can tell that's just like a
bad move
he exploded and the breath of fresh air
was gone forever i was he said again
a no-good son of a [ __ ] and a disloyal
liar
i had continued true i had he continued
tried to sink
angel and others in the brigade for my
personal gain as the ig
general barnes stepped out of his
trailer and franklin hailed him
general do you know what this colonel of
yours did he said
shoving his finger into my chest he
illegally warned general
allen of an investigation we had talked
about
so things are going sideways
um
yeah and that it was sort of
the the re i didn't even cover the the
thing that he did
because it was like it was almost
nothing
i called ed northington who had been uh
alan's aid it was now
in his new job and asked him if he had
heard about the investigation
is it general in trouble no that's what
he did
he like basically gave a heads up and
but it was like a little bit outside the
chain of command so uh
general or sorry colonel franklin freaks
out
fast forward a little bit he is in
hawaii
with on leave
with his wife mary grace mary grace
finally asked him about vietnam
a royal screw up i said you're anti-war
tony herbert
no that's not what i mean i mean i'm
just disgusted by what i've seen
happening to the army i said
she looked puzzled i had already told
her about getting battalion command
and though she knew it meant that i
would be more vulnerable to injury or
death than i was as
an ig she took it as a as she'd always
taken my career
she was proud she said but now she
looked bewildered as i talked about
some of the things i had seen this war
is not only killing our people it's
ruining our army the whole damn
show is run without leaders and we're
losing really losing
we talked the rest of the afternoon and
finally she asked about what would
happen when my
vietnam tour was finished wait till you
hear this i said grinning
you're going to quit she said throwing
me some sand my way
right colonel herbert wrong mrs herbert
i've got orders for the command and
command and general staff college at
leavenworth oh tony that's great
and after that i'm going to try and
finish my doctorate maybe then i can
really contribute something to the army
fast forward a little bit i kissed mary
grayson lay back in bed staring out at
the ocean through the glass doors at the
end of our room
i thought about them all night and about
the years that it passed
and the things that had happened to all
of us now was 1968
and i was 38 years old i had a wife and
daughter and i had killed one hell of a
lot of people
and watched a lot more suffer and cry
and die and now ma was gone
and paw and sister irene
you are what you are you dumb ass
lithuanian i thought that night as the
moon illuminated the far end of the room
you are what you are
and what you always wanted to be
a soldier
gets back to vietnam
and
i'm just going through so much of this
book like i'm just skipping so much
there's so much detail in here about all
these different things that he's dealing
with these relationships that he has
with colonel franklin
and and general barnes and how these
things are just going sideways and
he gets this one point take a look take
a look at this and please read it all
before you comment ray said
handing me a file folder the
investigation had been handled by major
henry boyer the executive officer of
second battalion
i flipped the cover sheet and turned to
the first page a three inch by five inch
color photograph stared at me
it was a picture of a vietnamese male
lying on his back in what appeared to be
a shell crater
his face had been blown away in guilt
beneath the picture was
engraved peace on earth from the
peacemakers c company 173rd
airborne brigade or something that
effect i glanced at ray
c company of second battalion he c
company of second battalion he said
i turned the page and read it through
well he said i put it down
on his desk it's a cover-up you're
you're damn right it's a cover-up
and little old paul here is not going to
be caught in the middle
you know what franklin wants he asked
without waiting for me to answer
franken wants it swept under the rug
there are exactly 50 cards out like that
he wants them
gathered and covered and what if that's
not possible
well then i guess we just have to put
the burden on christ
he said referring to captain christ the
company officer of
sea company so like it's just big
cover-ups going on
make this go away no one everyone's
worried about their career
all right through
through all through through all this
chaos
and he's he's been the ig at the 173rd
and you don't think he's gonna get a
battalion
because he's kind of created these bad
relationships but he ends up
getting tasked getting awarded getting
tasked getting charged with taking over
second battalion
so he's gonna be working for the guy
that has hated him as the ig
as i walked back to my sack that night i
decided to use the next 24 hours as prep
time i wanted to work out the second
battalion in my mind i laid down and
began and
in the states you might be able to go in
and take your time with changes but not
in vietnam in the states you could look
around for a bit and maybe take a couple
weeks before actually making a change
but in vietnam it was a different story
take your time in vietnam and men died
or lost legs or arms or eyes
so i had already been looking and thanks
to my opportunities as an ig
and and kotra's help i knew about as
much as
anybody could know about second
battalion and it all boiled down to one
primary conclusion
like the entire brigade the second
battalion was fat in every area except
combat
the solution was to trim
and he goes on about how he's gonna get
rid of people
or move people into more combat roles
because there's all these people that
are not doing combat
fast forward a little bit i didn't like
the way nicholson had handled
the men who were on the way home
frequently they would come back to the
rear as much as 30 days before they were
scheduled to depart
that was a bunch of crap i had learned
my lesson in korea
rotation had been established and tigers
became
[ __ ] so what he's talking about there
and we covered that in
in the last podcast
in world war ii when you went on
deployment for the war you went on
deployment for the war
you were going to get to go home when
the war was over and korea
is when they started hey you're going to
deploy for a sixth a year you're going
can deploy for a year and then you get
to go home
well what does that do well according to
him it turns tigers into [ __ ]
they had hung back and played it safe
until they until we wised up and came up
with a new policy
he who fought up front went home up
front
i didn't have the authority to establish
that policy in vietnam but i did have
the authority to decide
who came back to the rear and when i
could make sure that a man kept his ass
in the grass until seven days before his
departure date
and i was determined that the battalion
would start rewarding
achievement rather than failure
under nicholson the last battalion
commander if a guy wrapped a sergeant in
the mouth or if he refused to fight
he came back to the rear sat on his ass
waiting
drinking seeing shows smoking pot and
screwing everything that
wiggled downtown until he was
court-martialed or
given an article 15 at which point he
would
pay a small fine for his vacation of
several weeks or months
then he went back to his unit and did it
again
but not with me every mother's son was
going to hump it
and carry his share of the load just
like the few already
out there there were other so that's
that's that's the uh secondary
consequences that you got to think about
or unintended consequences that you got
to think about
hey if echo charles you know punches his
platoon sergeant
well we're going to send him back to the
rear and what's he going to do at the
rear get drunk
you know smoke pot get a vacation
have to pay a small amount of money then
you come back right out and do it again
because you don't want to fight
you're actually giving you what you want
yeah it's kind of like the kid the
teenager
right with the with the videos like
he gets punished and sent to his room
but then in his room is like video games
and magazines and you know all this
stuff
his phone internet yeah all this stuff
so he'll go
you know when things get tough in real
life
you know go mow the lawn i don't know
whatever he'll he'll act up
get sent to his room yeah yeah that's
why the punishment the modern day
punishment
with kids with teenagers is phone yep
give me that phone yeah it's brutal my
my kids like if i say that to my kids
they're like
wait wait what squares them away quick
dude
you ever seen ozark i have not seen it
okay so it's like
anyway i don't go too deep into it but
basically they're they're
put over simplifying it they're running
from these the drug cartels
so they're trying to leave they're
trying to disappear
and so it's like two two kids one is 12
one is like i don't know 16 17.
the girl and then the two parents so the
parents are like hey we gotta go we're
changing our identities
and all this stuff so here give me your
phone the girl just starts flipping out
and it's kind of one of those things
where yeah man like some especially
kids well it depends on who you are but
a lot of times kids are so attached to
that phone oh yeah like it's
such a big deal it's the social thing
like you know when i was a kid
you know you would get grounded right
which meant
you you couldn't see your friends yeah
you couldn't see your girlfriend you
couldn't see your
bros like you were grounded
well nowadays you like you said you can
send it to room but you're still going
to hang out with your friends because
you're going to be on snap
chat right that's what's going to be
happening yeah so
sending them to room doesn't really it's
not really grounding them the way you
ground them is you got to get that
device get that phone yeah there's so
many kids that are mad at me right now
for putting out this word
hey what's article 15 it's uh
if i'm your commander and you
you do something wrong then
you can be punished under the
uniform code of military justice the
ucmj
article 15. article 15 means that
i can dock your pay i can reduce your
rank like
i can apply punishment to you now
you have to op you can you can say you
can accept
you can accept the ucmj or you can say i
want a court martial in which case
you're going to get a lawyer and you're
going to get a jury and all that kind of
stuff
so article 15 is is it going to be
lesser it's a little bit of a gamble
sometimes depending on
you know what you did and because you
could say
you know if i'm your boss and you did
something wrong
people might be telling you just dude
just take just take article 15 and you
know jocko's pretty lenient you know he
he's a pretty or people might be like
you don't want to do ucmj you don't want
to go article 15 with jacqueline he
crazy
he's going to throw a book at you so
it's kind of like what like a
i guess not like a plea bargain then
because you know not like a plea bargain
um it's just accepting your fate gotcha
with
what your boss is gonna your boss has
the the authority
article 15 ucmj to say okay echo charles
he stole a piece of gear from the
platoon
we're kicking him out of the plate well
he's to go to ucmj so
you go to you go to me i'm your boss
and i say okay you stole gear we're
taking your trident you have to pay back
the money
i'm busting you down in rank and you're
going to go to the brig for 30 days
there you go now you could let's say you
didn't you thought you didn't steal it
and you you wouldn't want to make a case
you could say i request court-martial
in which case and now we go to court
marshall now you get a lawyer that says
he was just borrowing that gear right
and everyone knows that that you're
lying
so that's the kind of similarity to
going to trial kind of you know
guys like no i'll take the plea i'll go
to trial so in that case it is
except for you don't necessarily know
what the bargain is
right so it's not like a plea bargain
it's almost like a blind
a little bit of blind yeah it's a little
bit of blind but
it sort of is a little bit of like hey
look i know i kind of did this
i'm throwing myself at the mercy of the
court yeah hey boss
i screwed up i'm sorry hit me
yeah like pleading guilty essentially in
a minor kind of way
because the you know you're kind of yeah
it's up to the judge how he's like okay
you're throwing yourself kind of that
kind of throwing yourself at the mercy
of the court
that's right what is forgive me by the
way i'm deviating
what are you and i've heard this i hear
you guys say this all the time taking
your trident what does that mean you're
not a navy seal anymore yeah
just straight up you can't get it back
can't go through the whole deal yep
um yep it's kind of everything right
not kinda that's everything but you're
still in the navy though
you can still be in the navy but that's
not your jam if you're a seal typically
it's not not your jam i remember
there was a guy that stole a pair of
sunglasses
from who from like another guy yep
they had his they had a
captain's mask the next day for a little
article 15 took his bird he was gone
like that
i was i was a pretty new guy because if
you're a thief in the teams
oh yeah it's brutal yeah you are gonna
get
you are to get crushed yeah like you
will get the
there's there's you can leave anything
out in the seal teams you can leave a
freaking
diamond uh uh encrusted
knife yeah and no one will touch it in
the teams
oh yeah you anything in the teams yeah
and that makes sense i mean especially
like especially when you're like a
cohesive or supposed to be cohesive team
you know oh yeah bro it's crazy yeah
you're gonna steal something
yeah that's like nuts unheard of and he
still
still serves his sunglasses too i mean
dang i know especially when you get
issued sunglasses hey
supply guy i need new sunglasses and i
don't even know what all the
circumstances were behind it because
let's face it we all have oakley's
back we're all wearing the same
sunglasses
so i don't know if a dude had some
engraving on there or scratched his name
into it or whatever but man this guy was
gone
and that makes even less sense when you
think about it because it's not like
you're not gonna wear them what are you
gonna do to steal them and put them in
your house under your pillow or
something like this
you're going to be wearing them around
who knows maybe there was other
things that i didn't know about i was a
nougat i didn't know anything they're
just like hey don't steal [ __ ] i'm like
cool
got it got it looks like we're not
stealing in the zeal teams
it freaking pissed me off one time when
we i wanted my first shipboard
deployment
and a guy stole i had my gear out
and a guy stole a knife
it wasn't from my platoon but just
somebody on the ship yeah maybe it was a
marine maybe it was a navy guy i don't
know
oh they didn't find him no we never
found him but same thing like what's
this guy gonna do he's
gonna hide that knife and then take it
home
and put it under his pillow like he's
not gonna be able to use it yeah because
we'll see him
yeah and then we'll throw him off the
ship
yeah man yeah and that makes sense you
even hear about a guy stealing from
someone else on the team it's like brah
like yeah you're no one's messing with
that guy anymore the
bro we had a guy's name i forget his
name he stole
a video game systems like a super
nintendo or something like that from one
of the guys in the dorms
on the football team both of them and
they were like it was weird because
yeah my friend uh his name's davey he's
the one who got
it stolen from him he was like looking
around for he's like you know you're
just confused
it's not like someone's gonna steal your
whole video get out of your dorm room
and he lives in the same dorm too so
it's not like what did you set it up
four doors down
that's what i'm saying so it was just
gone so he was confused and then after a
while it's like no someone stole this
you know
so they you know they went through the
thing and they were like dusting for
prince which was like you know that
doesn't matter because everyone comes in
and out of the dorm so it just doesn't
didn't even matter
but i think davey was suspicious of this
guy i don't know if he became
suspicious or he was already suspicious
so
and he went to his room and just was
like
you know what i'm going to get to the
bottom of this thing and he was like
asking him he was like no what are you
talking about all mad or whatever it
became this big thing
and then he looked and in the dorms
there's these beds right the beds are
like that and you can like
take there's like a drawer under the bed
and all this stuff right
you know everything gotta fit uh gotta
fit in the door
so he pulled out the drawer of the bed
and like
took you know you can take out the
drawer so he unhooked it and like took
it out and boom there it was davey did
that
davey did that too yeah the guys it was
a call
out essentially but you know when you
call somebody out you better get the
stuff because you're gonna look dumb
you must have been super suspect then
yeah he was like because that's weird
too
imagine accusing someone right yeah but
also you can kind of tell
well yeah i'm looking at someone you can
tell yeah and consider
you could smell the freaking lies yeah
and usually but and consider even i mean
i'm sure it's like this in the military
too where
you kind of consider who could or had
the opportunity
or whatever and if they did what would
they have done it's like oh they he
couldn't you could
freddie at freaking practice the other
day and i come home and my shit's gone
exactly right yeah so i think there was
that kind of going on as well
and then he had some circumstantial
evidence then he read his face
and probably so they arrest him straight
up everyone was like oh my god i can't
believe this
even happened like why would you do that
it just wasn't computing for a lot of us
and boom they arrested him he was in
jail so this guy i remember his name i
don't want to call him out it's too mean
but
he uh so he calls the coach like you
know
you know when you're in college let's
face it like you get into some sort of
thing
you say hey coach i'm in this thing like
what can we do to sort of you know
work it out um so he calls the coach
and he's like hey this is what happened
i'm in jail i think he needed to get
bail out because he didn't live in
hawaii he was from the
from the mainland so it's like you know
it's hard he's like anyway he's called
the coach
and the coach um you know he hears the
story and he goes
right in there [ __ ] hangs up that's
what i like to do
that's what i like yeah don't like
thieves no
don't be stealing don't steal
otherwise here you're going to get ucm
jade article 15. all right
um going back to the book here there
were other things running through my
mind
that night tactics for instance the
infantry maxim was just a slogan and i
wanted it to be
in practice find them fix them
fight them and finish them but it simply
wasn't being used
i wanted to change that find him use
reconnaissance and intelligence the
reconnaissance platoon is being used as
a special ambush unit rather than for
reconnaissance the battalion had to have
eyes and ears
its area of operations was bordered on
the east by the south china scene and on
the what
south china sea and on the west by a
string of mountains running north and
south
from those ridges a trooper with
binoculars could see in most cases all
the way to the sea
but it wasn't being used fix them fire
and maneuver
one pins them down with fire while the
other runs up around the rocks
and comes in from the flanker from the
behind fire maneuver
have always been the key to infantry
success
but in vietnam we were just calling in
artillery and backing off to wait
the next day we would go in and pick up
the pieces and generally there weren't
any except for the women and kids who
hadn't had the sense to make it out of
the area
fight them close with and destroy the
enemy the military enemy
kill them or capture him but emphasize
prisoners because they give information
that leads to more prisoners dead men
are just dead men
capture them if possible but if not
finish them off for good
i lay there in my sack that night trying
to put it all together in my mind
where i had been and what i had done and
how i got to where i was at that very
moment in time and space
i was alive i decided because of two
things sheer luck
and not forgetting i attributed it to
nothing else
but i knew that the presence of mind had
a great deal to do with one's fortunes
i also knew there were some things
beyond anybody's control
they just happened regardless of
planning or preparation or skill or
courage or cowardice
i went to sleep thinking about all that
the next day i poured over my battalion
plans again
and when i hit the sack the next night i
knew i was ready as i'd ever been
i slept well
so
i'm gonna jump through some of this
stuff right now this is where he starts
he takes over the battalion he starts
squaring things away he starts going on
operations
he's still having it's not an overnight
process it's not like the battalion oh
there's a new commander like we're good
to go now everything's perfect
it's not like that um and as he's
starting to dig into the he's going on
some ops he's starting to dig in to try
and find out
how to get the get the platoons moving
in the right direction
um he's got he sits down to talk to one
of one of
uh these lieutenants he's talking this
lieutenant and the lieutenant kind of
this lieutenant doesn't want to go in
the field doesn't want to go in the
field
and he's trying to figure out why and
the lieutenant says you know not with
this particular leader
and he says why not and he's kind of
doesn't want to say anything he finally
says tell me and he
and then he says he opened up he had
been a platoon leader and his group had
policed up a detainee
from a village that had reported the
details to a ceo
over the company net the platoon began
to tie up the
the detainee for extraction when the co
called back
the lieutenant told me the ceo said what
they had out there was a kia
a dead dink a body count of one to which
the lieutenant replied
that he did not have a dead person but a
detainee in reasonably good health so he
says
no what we have is a dead dink killed
trying to get away the lieutenant
continued so what did you say i asked
well i told him the guy might be a
civilian
and what did he say he said that wasn't
hardly possible because once he's dead
he's a dink which in fact was about the
only way it was played in vietnam
regardless of what a person might have
been before he was killed
afterwards he was a dink very
very damn few people ever reported
killing a civilian regardless of how
unavoidable the death might have been
and very damn few dead civilians
failed to be included in body counts it
was time to stop the lieutenant though
before his narrative went beyond the
point of no return
i held up my hand hold do you do you
understand did that make sense because i
know i jumped into the story
so basically this young lieutenant is
there they have a detainee that they've
captured
and he calls his company commander and
says hey company commander
i got a i got a captured individual i
got a detainee
you know what do you want me to do and
this the the commanding officer calls
back and says you don't have a detainee
you have a killed in action
and you know that the term dink
obviously this is a slur
and but it doesn't just mean it means
enemy that's what they're saying if you
kill someone their enemy
wait so is he implying that you should
he should kill him
yep yeah okay and he's about that's what
he's he's about to get to that part
and and colonel herbert says hold on
yeah and he he says hold it
i cautioned him sir look before you get
too far
there are some other questions but first
you have to realize that if you say what
i think you may be going to say
i'm gonna have to report it therefore
it's only fair in fact
by the regulation in fact it's required
by regulations and the ucmj
that i make you aware of your rights do
you understand
yes sir well then let me ask you this do
you understand your rights under article
yes sir i do well let me go over them
again for you anyways
you don't have to say anything anything
that you say
can be used in court you can stop right
now or or you can continue or you can
have a military council right here
while you do talk if you wish and that's
in that's it in a nutshell
now do you want to go on since i've gone
this far
for christ's sake lieutenant at least
think before you answer my next question
okay okay
was the execution in fact carried out
yes sir
it was now lieutenant here comes the big
one and let me state again that you
neither have to answer
nor are you expected to answer just
because i'm your commander
if it's going to incriminate you i want
you to understand that part for sure
do you yes sir i do all right then
who actually did the killing he started
to answer
and then stopped abruptly abruptly sir i
prefer not to answer that one right now
if it's okay with you
that's your prerogative you keep this to
yourself until i get back to you do you
want to put it in writing
i think that i think i'd better do that
good he said
i said handing him a pad bring it back
when you finished
and forget about going out with c
company right now it can wait
so obviously bad situation
um he starts to run it up the chain of
command who's that include franklin
what does franklin say what the hell
kind of commander are you he asked it's
none of your business what occurred
before you assumed command
i'll back it up with an investigation i
said there'll be no
investigation says franklin it's
required sir i
god damn it herbert i'll handle it i
said i'll handle it and i will
if anything is done it will be done with
the general's approval
and it will be done by me can you
understand that much
i understand sir do you want a statement
from major boyer i want nothing until
i'm ready which means i don't want
anyone discussing it either
it's bad
um so while he's dealing with all this
and while he's continuing to create
friction
and again there's so much of this and
there's so much in this book
so many good lessons here's here's a
lesson he's talking about
planning and how he planned because he's
still leading troops he's still they're
still doing all kinds of operations
he says this to his troops i want you
all to come up with the plans and
recommendations i told them
and i meant it hell i didn't profess to
be an expert in anything
and by the way if you're a leader just
write this whole thing down
i didn't profess to be an expert in
anything i was the dumb son of a fine
coal miner
and i could use all the help i could get
if anybody came up with a brainstorm
i damn sure wanted to hear about it and
that includes suggestions for a commando
raid on hanoi
from doc talley i concluded i really
wanted to listen to them
because if a man makes a contribution to
a plan
he has a material interest in making it
succeed
so the trick is to forget about taking
credit for ideas and to persuade
others that they are their own
take notes i talk about that
very thing all the time
he also says i thought out everything
and tried not to waste words or time
frequently may have appeared
to have been spur of the moment response
but it was generally prepared
even though they were volunteers as all
paratroopers are
the grunts were different the grunts
were by nature different
they were not career men in the same
sense that officers and most of the
senior ncos were career men
and they were not sensitive to
opportunities for promotion or
self-aggrandizement
but because individuals are aggressive
and competitive by nature
the grunts did require an opportunity to
express those instincts
or in a word a chance to operate i knew
the grunt
hell i was one of them i promoted grunt
to be sure but still a grunt
i'd been an enlisted man all over half
my entire career
i had fought as one and been wounded as
one and i understood what made a grunt
tick because i knew what made me tick
i'd also been fortunate enough to gather
enough psychological insight
to comprehend them and myself even more
deeply and thoroughly
at the same time gaining enough military
experience to recognize
that they were the best raw material in
the world
they were bigger and healthier and more
intelligent and better educated than any
soldier the us
army had ever had the opportunity to use
before
and they were superior to any soldier
any other country was getting
even with our training shortcomings and
there were by god plentiful
the grunts in vietnam were still the
best trained men around as well as the
best fed
and best equipped moreover i think i
recognized something that must have
slipped by most of the brass
including westmoreland and later abrams
that the length of the hair on a man's
head wasn't nearly as important as the
caliber of the brain
inside
i knew that the grunt was a man just
like me
and that he was entitled to the same
respect i
myself demanded
his dignity was sacred it could never be
changed the commander could scream and
rant and rage and curse like a sailor
but he could never
encroach on the trooper's dignity
if the leader attacks his trooper's
dignity the trooper has but two
alternatives
to fold up roll over and die or strike
back
i was determined to follow the pattern
that had worked for me
in the past to allow my men to make at
least as many of the same kind of
mistakes as i had made
and god knows i had made my share and
more to deal with them honestly
to to express admiration respect love
patriotism
and my own conviction that he
represented with all my faults
with all its faults the greatest country
in the history of civilization
and the mightiest combat arm this
universe ever assembled under a single
power
to persuade him that it not really been
equipment and mass production that had
won world war one
world war ii and korea for us but rather
blood
guts courage know-how and a steadfast
devotion
to a cause
respect your people
i laid out the strategy for my battalion
it was some lousy war when a piddling
battalion commander had to lay out a
master strategy but that's the way it
was
hell nobody else laid out anything for
these men either from a national or an
international perspective
i owed it to them to give them some kind
of purpose and a reason
at the battalion level at least
got to know why you're doing what you're
doing and he's saying they're not even
hearing that
fast forward a little bit in fact the
whole damned u.s army in vietnam was
crazy
the generals westmoreland abrams piers
rossen de pew
richardson ewell ramsey and the rest
were all working on the premise that
they were the best and that whatever
problems we were having were the fault
of the commanders at lower levels
not my fault [ __ ] [ __ ]
the major leadership problem in vietnam
was the generals
and the rest of the senior officer corps
the colonels the lieutenant colonels
and the majors the captains lieutenants
enlisted men weren't to blame
the generals were has beens or never
bends from world war
ii vintage who had paper images built up
by the public information people
so again you know we're we're we're
reading this book
and really he's placing the blame on
everybody else which is not good
but he's telling what it looks like from
his perspective
he says about those generals they walked
and talked like leaders and wore ribbons
and uniforms it was only reasonable
that back in washington they were
regarded as leaders and were listened to
if you were in the military you must be
a great leader
right this we still have that anybody
that was in the military must be a great
leader
it's like i wish it was true it's not
always true
unfortunately
um again
he wasn't just talking this guy's not
just a talker this guy's not
when he's talking smack about these
other leaders
he's not just talking smack and and
saying oh they're not leading
he's leading he's actually leading
there's all kinds of
stories in here here's one i crossed the
yard they're out on a mission i crossed
the yard to the bunker and nailed myself
up against its outer edge
chew hoy i shouted using the name of the
program we had set up for leniency in
return for immediate unresisting
surrender chew hoy as always there was
no response
i waited then stepped back and fired two
quick rounds into the sandbags
around the doorway then stepping back
against the wall i lifted a grenade from
my belt
the old woman on the porch screamed and
there was one hell of a scuffling inside
the bunker bunker
they tripped all over each other coming
out hands first chu hoy chu hoy micho
hoy
chu hoy they were shouting i figured you
were i mumbled to myself
there were three of them two in khakis
and the wounded guy
stripped down to his shorts i nudged
them toward warden
keep them covered i said i'll get the
bunker i'll get it sir schmidty said
trotting across toward me god damn it
keep that group covered i shouted
i'll get the damn damn bunker we all get
paid by the same people
i don't think it was bravado it was just
that i had learned
years before that if you wanted to be
followed then you had to get your ass
out and lead by setting the example
if i expected other people to go down
inside bunkers and holes after the enemy
then i had better be ready to do it
myself
this time it was my turn i kept my rifle
in front
someone shouted grenade and the others
hit the dirt i dropped the one knee
holding my head down low in front of my
shoulders
i saw the guy break out of the bush out
of the bush with another grenade in his
hands i squeezed twice on the trigger
and watched the rounds
slam into his chest driving him up
against one of the palms bouncing him
off into the bushes two of our men had
been hit by the explosion
i didn't remember even hearing the
grenade detonate except vaguely perhaps
that's how unimportant grenades were for
me at least
i had seen them all over the world and
had used them and it had them used
against me over and over
i did not respect them as a weapon they
were charges
they blew up and out lay one at arm's
length
stay down flat and the worst you would
do
was give you a concussion run and you
got some shrapnel in your ass
watch him i said and turn to larae that
grenade came from the building
you take that side and i'll take this
one i turned the muzzle of the m16 west
and followed it around the building
i heard larae fire just then a grenade
exploded and i got the building just in
time to see larae kicking away
the reeds and dragging the body from
between the false walls
the guy had been wedged into a section
about the size of a bird cage
larae nudged the bloody the bloody body
with his foot
a loser sir he said quietly gently with
that same catch in his voice that you
hear in the movies just before tears
a goddamn loser dink he rolled it over
gently the guy had been a real
trooper and he had tried to do just as
he'd been told
just as so many of our kids had been
told and would have tried
had they been in his place uncle ho
would never even know the poor bastard
was dead nor would he have given a [ __ ]
if he had known
like those on our side he was just
another statistic
we left them there in the dirt
we started back down the trail at a trot
an outright
run was out of the question because more
than likely if you broke out of the bush
running you were a dead ass even at our
speed it was more than a few seconds
before we reached a large grassy
clearing
the american lieutenant the advisor was
on my left as we entered the clearing
and the rest of were standing around in
no particular formation
across the clearing i saw one man a
vietnamese holding
the young girl's hair with his left hand
bending her head back
bearing her throat his right arm
was around her neck and a knife in his
right hand was dug deeply into her flesh
beneath and to the left of her esophagus
all he had to do was pull and she was
gone
one of the children was hanging onto her
pajamas screaming
and the other child's face was being
steadily squashed into the sand by the
foot of another vietnamese soldier
the child was suffocating i shoved the
american lieutenant out of the way and
shouted something
staring at the guy with the knife in the
girl's throat he was staring at me too
and these these vietnamese these are
south vietnamese soldiers and this the
first person that he pushed out of the
way was a was an american advisor
so he he comes on this scene in this um
in this clearing and there's an american
lieutenant he pushes that guy out of the
way and these vietnamese soldiers that
the
american lieutenant was an adviser to
all this is happening
so these are these are south vietnamese
soldiers with it with the
the young girls yep holding the hold the
knife to this young girl's throat so
this is a
ally so this
vietnamese soldier's staring at herbert
with a knife to the girl's throat back
to the book with great ease
he pulled the blade across her blood
spurted and gushed down the front of her
pajamas and she dropped to the darkening
sand
pulling the child with her it took no
more than a second from the instant he
moved the knife until she crumpled
in a lifeless heap her baby still
screaming still pawing at her legs
her killer jumped back into the group of
vietnamese pulling with him the guy
who'd been suffocating the child
i should have shot them on the spot
while i could still identify them
the rest of the detainees were lined up
against the bushes
four of the men were already dead lying
off in the grass
to my right with their heads blown away
a vietnamese
soldier was parading up and down in
front of the survivors waving a pistol
i noticed that one of the four dead men
was the stud we had captured in the hut
i felt myself go empty something drained
from me in that moment
that you that i have yet to replace you
dumb son of a [ __ ] i screamed grabbing
the american lieutenant by the by his
shirt
in that instant i was only a flicker a
flick away
from killing him it passed i calmed and
turned him loose
just what the hell did you let happen
here lieutenant
he was only an advisor he said there
they were only doing a job
they knew their business guerrillas
weren't protected under the geneva
accords
they were following orders oh god i
thought
a big badass american who had never
killed anyone in combat or captured a
single prisoner legitimately had played
hell with these poor devils
big bad-assed all-american boy god i was
frustrated
i raised my hand to slap him clear
across the area i lowered it
you get all your scrap together and then
get the hell out of here i screamed at
him
sir i have a job i glance down at the
four dead men and over to the woman's
body not anymore you don't lieutenant
he was staring at me with what seemed to
be disbelief i moved as near to him as
possible without touching
now get your people out of here out of
here i said quietly and calmly
you're finished here the rest of this
like the charges
will take care back at base
so he witnesses this this this atrocity
and gets back to base
runs it up the chain of command tells to
frankly
franklin frankly franklin
he tells franklin what happens
uh franklin finally asked what had
happened and i told him every last sword
detail right down to the blood leaping
from the girl's throat
herbert you're a goddamn liar he said
i assured him i wasn't lying there are
other witnesses sir
then you're exaggerating he said did the
american did the lieutenant take part
yes sir he was in charge he had assumed
responsibility
from sergeant warden but did you see him
do any killing
no sir i didn't then you're a goddamn
liar there were no u.s personnel
involved he said
god damn it herbert you're always coming
in with these wild ass exaggerated
stories trying to make trouble
what the hell is wrong with you you're
getting carried away maybe you're
getting too old
a day or two so so they start going
through and this is what's really
interesting about this book is they have
like the the actual documents
from this guy ward and i sergeant first
class warden during the period of 14
february that's valentine's day 1969 was
a platoon sergeant
for so he explains what he saw happen
and you can get this book and read those
documents
then this happens a day or two after the
saint valentine's day massacre which we
just read about a black trooper named
white
refused to go into the field and offered
his refusal loud and clear
out in the battalion street where he
could be heard by one and all
you're going out white just like
everybody else i told him
like hell i am you son of a [ __ ] i
ain't fighting for no whities
right white you're going to fight for
your country
or for your dollars or for anything else
you can think of but by god
you're going like hell i am he said
taking off his glasses
and slamming them against the ground
they were unbroken he stepped on them
and ground them into tiny pieces
now you bastard he said i ain't going
cause i can't see
i shrugged and laughed at him so i'll
have you put on a listening post
guys with bad eyes always do better at
night you dumb son of a [ __ ] he laughed
you don't understand you send me out
there and i'll desert
no you won't white because out there
baby ain't back here
you leave the guys out there and you're
on your own
i tapped them on the chest but listen
i'll tell you what i'll do
you go awol out there and make it back
here and i'll give you a bronze star
and even if you don't i'll see to it
that you get a purple heart
out there when you're on your own you're
anybody's
and everybody's meat if vc
or nva don't get you the locals will you
are money
and they're all bounty hunters i'll cut
out as soon as i get back then
no you won't because you either
straighten out here you either
straighten out out there
or when the company returns you'll be
transferred to a unit that replaces them
he reached into his shirt pocket and
pulled out another pair of glasses
he was swaggering away he was swaggering
as he walked away
toward the helicopter big guy big bad
guy you'll get yours baby
the best i could do is hope that the
best i could hope for
would be that he would do a good job it
was his only chance if he didn't cut it
he was going back out with the next unit
just as i had promised
it was the only way reward the right
response and do everything you can
to get it most of the time it worked
with white it didn't so just to kind of
debrief that
we we heard earlier about his policies
he doesn't want to punish people for
acting badly so if this guy
with his old battalion commander acted
this way he'd get okay you're
you know you're in trouble you need you
know you need to go stay in the barracks
and you're gonna go to you know ucmj and
whatever but he's not gonna go fight
which is what he actually wanted so
his deal is not only are you gonna go
fight
but if you don't do a good job when this
when this platoon gets back from this
mission you're going out with the next
platoon until you do a freaking good job
he performed poorly in the field just as
he vowed he would
and i had him held at the gate when his
unit came back
i had asked childers which is his senior
nco to get the very best trooper he
could find
to guard white until the replacement
unit he was going to join came
out someone who wouldn't scare
and he came up with pfc schnelling
don't take any crap from him i told
schnelling and watch out the unit coming
out will pick him up
that was it except that schnelling
drilled him through the head and killed
him right outside the gate
white had some words and schnelling had
paid no attention
white had made a threat and then gone
for his rifle
he got it to his shoulder before
schnelling squeezed the trigger
and the mp at the gate had seen and
heard it all
thank god it was that cut and dried
schnelling had done his job i brought in
the criminal investigation division
people
they questioned everyone took statements
and that was it
except that later in the day i had
schnelling into the office
a crowd of white's friends gathered
outside
chanting we want schnelling we want
schnelling
he killed a brother he killed a brother
we want schnelling
freaking nasty and this is like horrible
so again just to make sure
everyone's tracking he puts
in the guy comes back he hadn't white
comes back hadn't done a good job
so he's got him standing by for the next
platoon that's going to go out
while he's standing by
herbert puts a guy to guard him this guy
named schnelling
schnelling's out there guarding him
white makes a move
schnelling kills him
luckily there's a witness which is the
mp
who had seen and heard it all
so and now they're in
the office of herbert and there's a
crowd out front
of white's friends saying we want
schnelling we watch nelly he killed a
brother he killed a brother
and here's what herbert does i reached
over and picked up my m16
look schnelling you are now a spec four
so he promotes him and says not because
you killed a man
but because you didn't fail to do it
when it was your job
now about that out there that's up to
you
i'll tell you what i'd do i'd walk out
there and end it right now
i'd pick out the biggest mouth out there
and walk up and explain the facts
tell them tell them that you just made
corporal
and if they don't clear out you might
take it into your mind to try for
sergeant
i jacked around into the m16 chamber
i'll cover you from up here
and if anyone so much as raises a weapon
i'll drop him
that's the least i can do i shrugged
he stepped through the door and walked
over to the group i could not hear what
he said but they dispersed and i never
heard white's name again
which is sad too that a man could die
and snap just fade out of people's minds
and disappear
gnarly want to talk about some
leadership challenges
that's like insane right oh yeah that's
insane
good i mean
does this kind of stuff still happen
like now no yeah it just seems so
almost like wild west ish
that that's that section right there
like that's a that's an insane the whole
thing is
freaking crazy yeah
yeah yeah that is crazy i mean like
there's so many elements too you know
where it's like all right
you you know you have a friend he gets
straight up just killed but
you know and it's like it's hard it's
one of those deals where you kind of got
to take sides a little bit or whatever
right if you're
if you're in that mix or whatever so
your guy your friend your brother
gets killed by another guy so it's like
all right we gotta seek vengeance this
is obviously out of line
obviously not part of this you know
we're all in the same team where you're
gonna kill this guy all you know
no matter what happened it's kind of
like you didn't have to kill him it's
easy to be like you didn't have to kill
him or whatever
so yeah of course so they want vengeance
they want justice they want like all
this stuff or whatever and
and they kind of have a point in in a in
a way especially if they don't know the
whole thing
they kind of have a point yeah well
you're also
let's face it there's a huge assumption
that the lone
mp is just of the
the big witness right this one i mean
what if what if
schnelling's friends with the mp yeah he
says hey i got this issue with this guy
yep or hey we just had beef and i shot
this guy you got me and he's like yeah
yeah
yeah i saw what happened he shouldered
his weapon right one guy
that's such a freaking nightmare and
then
okay and then it gets worse so where
you know he's he's like hey this is what
you should do this is what i would
describe
go out there let them know and the thing
is bro that's not gonna i mean of course
it worked right but
we don't even know what he said we don't
know in the moment before he went out
that's not gonna work bro these guys
like they wanna they wanna kill me i
already
know i already killed their guy like
we're at war right now where there's a
war within the war going on right now
here's what here's the only thing that
makes me think
well how it turned out you think well i
i wonder if his friends were kind of
like
look we know white and white was kind of
like he
maybe he you know maybe they knew what
type of person he was and he knew how
that he was close to the ragged edge or
whatever
yeah but god i don't even know what to
say about this
like it's just a freaking nightmare
this whole book is freaking crazy like
when you think
look at what we just read you got this
freaking soldier killing another soldier
you got the woman getting her
throat slashed there's four other people
executed
it's madness it's madness
all right under what circumstances do
you
slay the girls through because obviously
that girl's not military nothing like
this
yeah i mean you know oh she's a vc
sympathizer that's
you know probably what their claim was
yeah
yeah i guess i mean i i will give you no
circumstances if that's what you're
looking for
right well i shouldn't say that you know
this
you know you could obviously be in some
kind of a hand-to-hand combat scenario
where you've got a
enemy fighter that happens to be female
could happen with her baby okay yeah i
mean there's
okay i guess in this scenario it makes
no sense whatsoever
in this scenario herbert's saying look
that's a freaking war crime
that's what he's saying that's what's
weird too like herbert he's
you know like on this like he's a
what i say earlier he's like straight
laced guy right he's like a straight
laced guy
and so when he sees stuff like that it
it's unacceptable to him
and and that's what's about the um about
the
guy white getting killed he's not the
herbert's not the kind remember herbert
remembering korean war
they go hey burn down this village he's
like i'm not gonna do it
they they bring that up and that's kind
of why i focused on some of that stuff
in um
when we did the last podcast you know he
had had this
he he mentioned that they had uh uh the
first black replacement showing up
and he was like we didn't you know we
don't what the troops didn't care
if you did a good job you we're we're
good he talked about the fact that he
was raised
um by that doctor that was like hey all
these people in the world
they're people like you they're out
there hunting trying to feed their
families so he's
seems like he's this kind of straight
laced for lack of a better word
good person
man i'd like to sit down with this dude
he's not alive anymore but
i know you haven't seen the movie
platoon you should watch it
it shows a lot of chaos mayhem but
all these things that you read all the
books you read about vietnam
and all the movies that you see about
vietnam like it's all wrapped up in this
in these scenarios that are just
freaking insane
i mean one of your soldiers kills one of
your other soldiers
after you say hey you you've got to go
out it's like nuts
and then you're thinking well look then
you're thinking is it worth it
like hey this guy white i could have
just said all right fine you're not
going out right fine
you go i'll put you on kp duty you can
go peel potatoes
you know what i mean and then what
happens with battalion then other people
like well i don't want to go out either
yep
so now what are we doing yeah yeah
i mean it kind of could be viewed as
like yeah man that's like
that's how it needs to be almost yeah it
could be and this is why
it's v you got to be very careful about
painting yourself into a corner
yeah right you got to be very careful
about painting yourself into a corner
in life especially as a from a
leadership position
if you paint yourself into a corner
you're painting in that corner there's
no moving
there's no moving so
for me as i look at this like okay i got
a guy that doesn't want to go out
what can i get from him what can i do
with him how can i
talk to him and again we don't know any
of the history of the guy we don't know
how
bad of a soldier he was we know his
behavior was i mean obviously he's
calling he's calling his commander like
a son of a [ __ ] and all this stuff so
he's not
you can tell he's not down for the cause
right so why is that how do we build a
relationship with that guy
and there's some guys that are totally
overboard right they're gone like you're
not gonna get him back
was he there and if he's there why are
you actually having him out on patrol
but if everything to you is kind of
black and white you're sort of
you're sort of like hey this is what
everyone this is what you're gonna do
and you have no
you painted yourself in that corner and
you have no way out of it
going back to the book i should never
have had any problems in vietnam because
it was an infantry war
infantry and helicopters
with a different quality of commanders
the helicopters could have played a very
important role in command and control
the unfortunate fact was that the
commanders kept their butts glued in the
seats and the birds
i don't think i can overemphasize the
weaknesses inherentness
from 1500 feet up war was simply a lot
of little guys
in green running here and there shooting
up the landscape
the bird men he's talking about the
commanders fast forward a little bit the
bird men
may have been commanders in the
technical sense of the word but they
weren't leaders and the grunts knew it
down there was their world it was a
ground war
an infantry exercise and as infantry
we could have won it man for man we were
better
and we could have won it with less than
half the people we had there
all we had to do was get rid of the
wasted headquarters
chaff get rid of the px's and the
steakhouses and the clubs and the
massage parlors and the pools
and the pizza houses and the
commissaries and get down to fighting an
infantry war
we had the training and we had the men
who could have done the job
the problem was not only a lack of
command leadership
but a lack of distinct mission we didn't
have one before i got there
we didn't have one while i was there and
we never had one after i left
but an army requires a mission it
desperately needs some direction towards
a specific goal
it was all charts and graphs for us with
machine
technicians like the west point
engineers running the show
i don't think we have to be conditioned
to kill we need no
training to destroy we're built for that
killing comes easy
establish no rules and leave a vacuum
and one
what you end up with are milai and kuloi
the absence of policy and mission was a
policy
in itself
need to need to know what the freaking
mission is
by the way in war freaking absolutely
i guess we'll in your normal life yes
absolutely in your business in your job
yes and you know what the freaking
mission is
fast forward as we continued to score
every night franklin began to increase
his visits to the field
finally he made it a point to be on hand
personally to
personally count the bodies and i found
myself as his constant
escort guiding him from one dead man to
the next and standing by while he
snapped photos
it was another syndrome the guys that
didn't kill anybody were the ones who
broke their asses to get a picture
what the hell it would probably have
been the same way with indian scallops
if we had cameras back then
so franklin is out there kind of coming
out and he goes through a bunch of this
stuff
there's a guy named grimshaw and we're
gonna hear his
name later
one of his company commanders grimshaw
said a dead vc is a dead
vc and a dead nva is a dead nva and a
dead vci is a dead vci
except of course wind killed by the
second battalion
then they're only dead if franklin
touches the touches
his toe to them and they better be
wearing a uniform and have a weapon what
the hell was i trying to do
franklin asked i had to be an ass to
move two
rifle companies that distance in the
dark why they might have opened up on
each other
if either of them had become disoriented
and besides he said it was one big waste
we could have taken them all in
accordance search and saved all the
inconvenience
so meanwhile while this stuff is
happening
the the the brigade is keeping
battalion scores they're keeping scores
to figure out who's the best battalion
who's the best battalion who's the best
battalion they keep track of a bunch of
different things
enemy killed an a killed an action body
count enemy
prisoners of war enemy contacts enemy
weapons captured
a number of a walls so who's absent how
many people you got absent without lead
how many article 15s have you done
meaning how many times have you punished
somebody
how many delinquencies have you had how
many malaria cases do you have
how many re-enlistments do you have how
many special courts do you have
and then they take all these different
numbers and they put them into like
one final number so
here's how the numbers shake out
basically they shake out that second
battalion
so herbert's battalion is winning in all
categories
it's not even close for enemy killed in
action
it's uh the other battalions are 14 4 29
and 36.
second battalion has 84. so
more than twice as much as the next
battalion for enemy captured
listen to these numbers eight
zero zero and three
how many does the second battalion have
90.
for enemy contacts it's 34 27 37
60 and 2nd battalion has 66.
for enemy weapons captured it's 15
11 3 and 17.
second battalion has 57 so there's not
even it's almost like it's not even
close
for absent without leave
so this is this should you want the low
number here it's 14 24 26 and 24
and what a second battalion have eight
they only have eight people that have
gone awol
for article 15s the numbers are 39 56 57
and 52.
what does second battalion have 24
for delinquency reports 17 9
11 10 2nd battalion has five
malaria they're all the same
re-enlistments listen to this
re-enlistments
the numbers are 0 0 40 and 0.
no one wants to freaking stay in what
does 2nd battalion have
so the total score and they have
whatever they have this way of
making all this into one number second
battalion for this particular month this
is february 1969
has 420 points
they're in the lead and then the other
ones are 180 145
70 and 20. i mean just combat
ineffective
right and they're and by the way this is
so they're getting graded
by franklin and and barnes
getting graded and they're crushing
second battalion under herbert is
absolutely crushing everything
but the hits just keep on coming there's
some military intelligence
interrogation rooms that are on their
little base
and herbert pays a visit i walked into
one of the rooms and back and knocked
lightly on the door one night
who's there herbert just a moment sir
someone answered
and second later the door swung inward
sergeant carmody
greeted me come in sir i squeezed past
him and closed the door behind me inside
in addition to carmody where captain
bowers a vietnamese man
and one of the honeys the wild cats had
captured in the morning
she was seated to my left in a chair
against the wall just off the corner
carmody was standing to her right my
left and the vietnamese man was sitting
just off my right foot facing the girl
in the chair
their knees only a couple inches apart
captain bowers was just behind the
vietnamese man sitting in a chair and
leaning over the viet's shoulder
the girl was moaning and trembling
find anything out i asked turning to
carmody she claimed she was out picking
water
bugs sir he said and laughed what patrol
where was it headed
what about what about the patrol where
was it headed carmody turned
to her and asked something in vietnamese
she shook her head
he hit her with the back of his hand
raking it down
along her face you're a [ __ ] liar he
shouted blood began to rush
into the long abrasion on her cheek
it began to happen in a rush i turned to
bowers thinking he would say something
carmody said something in vietnamese
bowers nodded the vietnamese man in
front of him
and touched his shoulder with his hand
the girl screamed
i glanced down and saw for the first
time that there were wires from her body
to a telephone between the viet's knees
he was cranking it i grabbed the wires
and yanked
damn near lifting the viet up with them
before the wires separated from the
phone
it clattered to the floor are you crazy
bowers i yelled
so just so you understand these these um
telephone
machines that you can power them by
cranking them this is an old-school
like telephone and so that's where he
they have these
they're basically electroshock electro
electrocuting her
are you crazy bowers i yelled sir i what
the hell kind of crap are you pulling
here sir i go get oh
oh kane sir major kane says i don't give
a damn what he says you go get him i
said
i turn to comedy and knock this off
until this thing is settled bowers left
and carmody the viet and i followed him
out of the hall leaving the girl alone
in the little room
in a moment bauer's return major o'cain
isn't here he said where the hell is he
he's gone down to brigade sir and behind
him
through the open doorway i saw the major
getting into a jeep
i left too and walked down to franklin's
office where not surprisingly o'kane was
still
deep in conversation with the deputy
commander franklin sigled to me to hold
up until he was finished
when o'kane left franklin called me in
and immediately began screaming
we were right back where he left off you
son of a [ __ ] he ran it
you dirty rotten son of a [ __ ] how many
times have i warned you to stay the hell
away from
am i or have your tap cut off it seemed
like the time for accuracy
four times sir i said and did you
understand yes sir but i understand
torture too
i don't give a [ __ ] about that i sir god
damn it
herbert don't you sir me i gave you a
direct order did you understand it yes
sir but they were torturing a vietnamese
did you personally see them torturing
this girl
at least he knew it had been a girl yes
sir they us soldiers
no sir this vietnamese god damn it
herbert how many times must i explain
the rules of land warfare to you over
here what the vietnamese do is none of
our damn business
but sir the guy was cranking this phone
generator while bowers was
who was cranking the generator this
interpreter
i guess and was he vietnamese yes sir
but and
was bowers cranking no sir but then god
damn it that's the end of it
o'cain said that's all there is to know
he lifted his hand and shook his finger
one more goddamn interference herbert
and you're all washed up and am i
understand no sir i don't carmody was
did you see carmody crank the phone no
sir did you see any u.s crank that phone
no sir then what's your [ __ ] it was the
first time i'd
had to really compose a sentence for one
thing i told him it was a violation of
u.s army directives
as well as geneva accords and the rules
of line warfare
and for another i finished it just is an
army
oh you son of a [ __ ] he said you're so
goddamn righteous
you never did anything like that right
no sir i haven't
he slapped the girl in and you never
have herbert is that correct
that is correct sir i but you saw
carmody slapper huh
yes sir i did and and so all at once
you're the judge the jury and the
executioner is that correct herbert
no sir i know sir i know sir i know sir
i tell you what you are
herbert you're a disloyal and you're
maybe getting kind of old
you just can't stomach it anymore what
the hell is the matter with you
look he said with relative benevolence
in his voice let me explain
these are the enemy even you must be
able to understand that right
these are the guys who killed your
buddies whom did she kill sir god damn
it
i'm talking about the enemy in general
he said raising his hand
let me put it this way their vc
i decided there was no sense in carrying
out this farce any further
and we were supposed to be soldiers and
we are supposed to be soldiers sir
american soldiers i want to make a
charge
i'd like to charge charge my ass you've
already made a charge and now it's an
investigation
and i'll take care of that not you you
just be able to back your mouth
with sworn verified testimony
sure i said sir anytime
[Music]
yeah so again it's very strange
uh not very strange but you can see this
guy he's seems to be trying to do the
right thing
but man he's making some enemies
and i guess big a big part of it is me
trying
my best to look at it from all or more
than
just herbert's perspective and you
kind of gotta admit when you think about
it where
you know when like okay when you're in a
complex situation and you have like a
goal
and then you have all these rules
and sometimes those rules do get kind of
looked over
some of them on a smaller level right
and sometimes it can be more efficient
meanwhile you got this guy who's kind of
by the book
and most people are most people i'm i'm
pretty
i almost want to say everybody's not
going to be by the book hundred percent
of the time
okay in one way or another yep and you
get a group of people and they're
they're they're carrying out a goal
whatever yeah
and and it's working and it's working
out
and they're okay well that's an
assumption yeah because it doesn't
because
because let's face it if we just look at
how well the battalions are doing
his battalion's doing the best and he's
kind of flying the righteous path
yeah yeah fully and and yeah this is
this
particular story aside i'm saying in
general okay and then you get uh whether
it be a new guy or just somebody there
who's always like how should it's not in
micromanaging but like nitpicking
on certain things and it kind of jams up
your whole approach to what you're doing
sure it could be better or not or
whatever
but it becomes kind of a nuisance you
know well
well okay i mean i i see what you're
saying
but let's let's remember that this guy
is witnessing murders
tortures sexual assaults which i didn't
really cover rapes which i didn't really
cover but they're in here
he's he's seeing all kinds of horrible
[ __ ] this isn't somebody this isn't all
these people are kind of bending the
rules to get the job done
this ain't that mm-hmm this ain't that
yeah fully and that's what i'm so
and that's what i mean just what you
said like people bending the rules to
get the job done
kind of a thing right we we understand
that yes and he understands it
right remember the guy that got told hey
bring back the mermites on your patrol
and and the guy says this is stupid and
herbert says well it's an order and he
says [ __ ] them
remember that part he's down with
bending the rules if the rules don't
make sense
right yeah fully and uh
and yes that is true and we got a good
bird's eye view of the whole deal
for sure but the guy
this guy that he's talking to franklin
yeah franklin from his perspective he
might be looking at it as hey we're
bending the rules to get the job done he
might be genuinely feeling that
he might be he might be now what you
have to
fall back on is you have to you have to
fall back and this is a tough one
you have to fall back not only on what
is the right thing to do
but you also have to bounce that off of
what is legal
oh yeah okay so for the young
leaders out there especially military
leaders but this applies to anything
this applies to business
because look there's thing there's
things you do in business where oh
there's the right thing to do and then
there's the wrong thing to do
and then there's the legal thing to do
yeah criminal
yeah and then yeah there's the criminal
thing to do so
when you're doing something hey listen i
can explain this
you know the the the cnn test have you
ever heard of this before
look if i can go on cnn and say hey this
is
why i made this decision and you don't
feel
shame because of what you did that's
definitely part of the test
the other thing you got to remember is
what is legal
because if you let and this is something
you can tell
your your your employees or your troops
you got to remember about what's legal
because someone
that should steer because look if if
if you're um let's say
you're you're in a platoon you're out on
a target and you
find somebody that's killed
americans right they freaking kill they
have the bodies
and you catch them with the bodies and
with the freaking bloody knife
there's almost no one that would say oh
okay well i don't feel like killing
those bad guys
right there's a guy with a bloody knife
you you see them
killing americans to say hey do the
right thing a lot of people like i know
the right thing to do is we kill that
guy we execute him
you have you have to remember that that
is not legal you are not allowed to do
that
so you have to get your people to
understand that
regardless of how you feel it's not just
a cnn test because that kind of passed
the cnn test hey
i showed up this guy had killed a bunch
of americans and we freaking
we i shot him and you can that's the way
it is
and i i feel no shame because of it you
pass the cnn test guess what you can
still go to
you can still go to jail it's legally
wrong
so as a leader what you have to do is
you have to sort of merge
all these ideas into one
final thought and you have to take the
fact that hey
what this is not legal to do this
this is not legal to do this now there's
others
we could come up with scenarios where
doing the legal thing
still isn't the right thing and it's
it's actually
wrong it's wrong to do that
and sometimes you may have to break that
rule but what we're talking about here
is they're doing things that are not
legal yeah so regardless of how you feel
you're doing something that is not legal
on a very
in a very big way these aren't minor
charges these are war crime scenarios
which
right this isn't like hey we bent the
rules we we left some freaking
mermites out in the field
which is pretty easy to argue right hey
listen my guys were already tired
we if we're gonna carry these things it
was gonna bog us down we had a better
chance of getting ambushed it was gonna
be a problem i left them
okay got it that's not
war crimes yeah fully so there's a
there's a difference
yeah yeah there does there comes a point
where it gets like you just can't defend
certain things
you know and most yeah especially when
you're talking about like
you got to remember though it's not even
just that you can't defend him because
if i roll up
and i find a an isis fighter that killed
three people you can defend that all day
you can defend oh yeah i saw him and
shot him
he killed three americans i saw him
doing it you can defend that all day
long
but it's not legal so now you got to
deal with the ramifications whatever
those are
yeah yeah
you ever seen the movie cobra no come on
sylvester stallone cobra
i have not seen it dang all right i'll
watch platoon you watch cobra no
not deal so there's a part there's a
part in the beginning where this psycho
guy takes over the supermarket or
whatever right
and cobra is kind of one of these guys
he uses excessive force you know
kind of like demolition man same actor
by the way sylvester stallone
either way so cobra ends up killing this
guy
right and then the the press comes not
cnn
but the press comes and they're trying
to interview cobra
and they're like he's like hey did you
have to kill him you know
did you have to die or did he do you
know uh
you know he has a right to live and all
this stuff or whatever and he's like
yeah he's
you know did you use excessive force and
all this he's like yeah use everything i
have
and he's like hey you know like um
people are pretty
are protected you know entitled to
protection by the law or whatever
and he says so he grabs the reporter
and unwraps or he uncovers
like one of the bodies right and he's
like you tell that to his family huh
he passed the cnn test is what i'm
saying yep
i think it was legal too though
technically it depends on the situation
it was like borderline so yeah yeah i
don't want to go into the movie what
happened
to to get cobra off the hook or nothing
like that but
nonetheless that's the cnn test you see
i'm saying yeah no that
so so the cnn test is but it's not a
it's not a unilateral test that just
because
it passes it's okay that's what i'm
trying to explain to young leaders
it's not just the cnn test it's the cnn
test
plus it's the legal test
is what you're doing legal or is it
illegal
and if it's illegal there are going to
be repercussions
even if you pass the cnn test
so as a leader you've got to pay
attention those things and what you have
to do is keep your troops out of trouble
it's incumbent upon you to keep your
troops out of trouble
because they they might be reacting
emotionally
and you're the one that's supposed to
reign them in and make sure that they're
not getting
not not doing things that are illegal
and i'm not saying those things aren't
deserved you know you find somebody that
just killed three americans that
that isis member deserves to die we get
it
not legal yeah that's allowed so where
did these go
and and my original point was like
franklin maybe to him it was he was
quote unquote like i said
um maybe bending a few rules or turning
a blind eye to
just small minor things and the means
kind of justified the end scenario
um and yeah you i agree i think that's
true where it's like but we'll remember
we're slitting a girl's throat
yeah yeah fully all right we have to
leaders
have to lead their troops to make sure
that they are not just doing the right
thing
that they're not just passing the cnn
test but they're also doing what's legal
otherwise there's going to be
repercussions that's just that's just
the way it is
that's the reality
all right back to the book when i
remember the folly of it all now i
rationalize a bit and tell myself that
there wasn't enough time to be fully
sensitive to the finality of death
for instance to say that it had not been
a very important day because the second
battalion had but two nva kills now
seems ludicrous
it was a damn important day for those
two dead men
when even just one man died or got his
fingers blown off or his leg shattered
or his hearing impaired
or his eyes bloodied and blinded it was
one hell of a costly battle
especially if you happen to be the guy
who got it that day
it's something generals and presidents
can never understand
only mothers fathers brothers sons
daughters and wives
maybe if i were a general or president
who never went to war with his men
or who never risked paying the same
price maybe i'd want to convert
the whole damn show into a statistical
table to be read solemnly
by some broadcaster every thursday night
generals and presidents are fine for
explaining to all of us
those things that we ought to be willing
to die for
but when the war is over all that's left
are
statistics and the generals and the
presidents
are always among the living
if anything has happened to our country
as a result of the vietnam war
it is that our national infection with
the sickness of the numbers game
we reduce the blood and the suffering
and the death
and destruction to mere ciphers and in
doing so
we reduced our own souls
numbers don't die people do
columns of figures don't disintegrate in
the explosion of a bomb
human beings do statistics don't bleed
and if you make your war a war of
numbers
you will have no trouble sleeping
most generals and presidents slept well
so this stuff is continuing on in
another
mind-boggling plot twist
on april 2nd 1969 barnes
gave me a letter of commendation from
general connors
who had replaced general piers as the
commander of the first field
force victor he also handed me a letter
from piers which had come all the way
from the states
piers was quite complimentary and barnes
added that the second battalion was the
best in the brigade
and that i was the best battalion
commander he had personally
ever known so that's franklin's boss
then he handed me his own letter of
commendation the scoresheet for the
brigade
which again listed the second battalion
as the top battalion and the official ig
report
which listed the second battalion as the
tops in the brigade
he also assured me that i would very
soon begin reaping the awards
rewards for my efforts as he called them
he said the distinguished service cross
was being prepared
and the general already had a verbal
assurance
it would be approved he's getting some
love i went back to the battalion and
sat down with
warm iceless bourbon my god what was
happening
two months of nothing but crap and now
all this in one day
maybe things really were going to be
different maybe the brigade was going to
shape up
with less than two and a half months to
go sweetness and light were in the air
and there were signs that everything was
going to be okay
but something else gnawed at me i had
reported
eight atrocities or war crimes or
whatever the hell they wanted to call
them
the abuse of the detainees at on k
the three torture incidents the murders
the looting the alleged murder of a
young lieutenant and the alleged
execution of the detainee
in the custody of the hero lieutenant if
i could get those things cleared up
i'd really be up to date and i knew
i'd better get my statements down soon
or i'd have to get them in writing from
back in the states
taking time out of the command and
general staff college at leavenworth and
i didn't expect to have that kind of
time
so yeah this all comes really clear
right now
i went down on the morning of april 3rd
so the next day to talk to franklin
about them
sir i jokingly said when i entered your
best battalion commander of yesterday
would like to have a talk with you today
okay sure herbert
come in he said have a seat i sat down
where he indicated
he was only it was the only chair in the
room what's on your mind
the eight allegations sir the atrocities
i reported i want atrocities he
interrupted
what the hell are you talking about
atrocities eight sir
and i took them off one by one counting
them on my fingers as i went
sir i'm going home in less than two
weeks and most of the other witnesses
have already gone
i'd like to get my part wound up now
while i still have
time and things are going kind of slow
god damn it tony he said the
investigations are ongoing what more can
i do
the next morning when i reported barnes
was behind his desk and franklin was in
the chair to his right
it was quick colonel herbert the general
said i'm going to replace you as the
commander of 2nd battalion
i felt the blood drain from my head
replace her you mean relieve
not relieve tony replace i'm giving you
a maximum efficiency report
and sending you to saigon it hit me like
a ton of rocks
it is is it over the allegations i've
made sir
franklin leaped to his feet screaming
that's right you son of a [ __ ] you and
your goddamn lies about beechem and
crouch and all the rest that poor
lieutenant
and every other one of your damn lies
and exaggerations
so clearly they were buttering him up
hey you've done great you're our best
battalion we've got you
we give you a maximum efficiency report
like you're the best guy
how about you just freaking keep the old
mouth shut about these allegations
and then when he brings them up again
they realize
he's gonna stick to his guns i felt cold
and empty then a wave of relief swept
over me and calm said and i stared at
franklin as though he were an
insect and i tried to speak as
deliberately and as coolly as i could
i'm not talking to you sir i'm trying to
speak to my commander general barnes
it stopped franklin's ranting and he
gave me the chance to turn back to
barnes
sir the very least you owe me is a
complete investigation
to see who really is telling the lies
and exaggerating
the general had his head down over his
desk scribbling on a
piece of note paper colonel franklin has
already investigated all your charges
and i'm satisfied he said
reaching out and handing me the note
you'll be out
on the landing zone in one hour there
are two planes leaving
for saigon today you be on one of them
your records will be ready for you and
on k when you're in saigon or anke when
you get there
you report to colonel lou ashley
in saigon it's on the note sir i said i
have a battalion i've signed for over a
million dollars worth of material and
equipment i just can't clear out in an
hour franklin broke in
one hour herbert one hour you'll be
picked up under arrest and taken out by
the provost marshall
one hour barnes said again i saluted
don't do me any favors with the
efficiency report i intend to see you
all again
so even though they said we're gonna
like we're gonna let you out of here
with uh a good evaluation he's saying
don't even
this dude does not play bro
um as i walked back to the battalion
i told myself it was important to remain
calm cool and collected i knew i had
them both
just as long as i didn't blow it they
had gone far beyond their authority in
removing me without any grounds for
relief i was convinced by then
that it had to be something more than
any allegations of atrocities hell
everybody knew about them anyways
somebody else would be bringing them up
again and soon if they thought that by
getting rid of me they were also getting
rid of the shame of what had occurred
then they that they had got it under the
rug they neither understood me
nor the army at that point i still had
faith in the system
i walked over to the talk ernie had most
of the officers gathered in the briefing
room
he had already told them look i began
there's no time to screw around
you know i've been given the boot that's
why i wanted to talk to you all right
away
i've only got about 15 minutes more
before i have to get out of here
but i wanted to take some time to thank
you and get the chance to shake as many
of your hands as i could before i have
to go
there were some protests and a few
remarks about quitting i stifled that
quickly
the army has a system of military
justice and rules and regs
so none of you needs to go off half
cocked and try and take things into your
own hands
nobody quits either just keep thinking
about the battalion
that's what's important not me if you're
if you quit you're letting down not only
me but every last one of those grunts
out here
they have to stay they can't quit you
can but many of them need you
and the guy who replaces me is going to
need you it's not going to be his fault
what happened to me
so stick with the battalion and stick
with him and stick with them i said
waving
toward the boonies i started shaking
hands
in the in the landing zone area men all
along the ground were lined up
pulling off smoke canisters of every
color in the rainbow
there were maybe a hundred men out there
and a hundred smokes
it was their honors smoke when the
troops were coming back after a kill
they buzzed the field with a smoke on
each skid
and when one of their own left they lit
one to five
depending on how well he was like liked
plus his reputation as a fighter
and i was looking down on at least a
hundred of them
knowing all the time that nobody was
that good
but choked up with appreciation
nevertheless
i waved and they waved back the pilot
banked the ship again
and i sat against the wall rigging and
wiped my eyes
we landed in saigon a bit before nine
o'clock that evening and although i
shouldn't have been feeling like a
bastard on father's day i didn't
although i should have been feeling like
a bastard on father's day i didn't
i was relieved in more ways than one i
suppose i reasoned that if barnes and
franklin had hated me that much
i was better off out of the outfit i had
the marbles in my pocket
they had nothing to fall back on but
their own lies and falsifications
i knew i had been lucky i could have had
accidental kills of women and children
or other non-combatants
and they would have had me had the
marbles in their pockets
i could have ranked second or third on
the ig inspection
i could have had a high court martial
rate or accident rate or a large number
of article 15s
or delinquency reports from the military
police
or any one of a number of other things
that could have been used against me
but i've been lucky frankly i'm used i
had let
franklin i'm used had let his personal
dislike for me get the best of him
it had forced him into a premature
confrontation
that i was bound to win
i was bound to win
well
it was not that clear-cut it was not
that clear-cut at all
and
the book goes on and it goes into a lot
of
detail and
there are all kinds of further
accusations and counteraccusations
and they end up making sworn statements
against herbert
including him leading the killing of
civilians so they start
making accusations against him
and this is and again these documents
are in this book that's one of the
things that makes this book so good is
it's got all this actual documentation
here
they they recommend revoking his orders
they recommend removing his opportunity
to to lead or be in command again
general russ who's the overall decision
maker on the case
agrees with the accusatory statements
kills colonel herbert's career so the
the idea that he was bound to win
no actually doesn't work out that way
colonel
herbert fights it he fights this spends
a bunch of his own money
so and then he goes on the offense
because he wanted investigations before
now he goes on the offense
charges uh brings charges up against
colonel franklin
14 separate specifications including
failure to report murders and church
torture
he does the same thing to general barnes
fail up failure to report
war crimes on multiple occasions so he's
going on the offense
it gets national publicity it's in the
news
the lead investigator for the army
this guy by the name of major carl
hensley
according to the book and i hate to say
that i'm just
because i don't know what i don't know
what the truth is according to the book
this guy major carl hensley had told
herbert like look we believe you
you're right we can win this thing
and then he kills himself kills himself
with a shotgun
you can you can look that one up it's in
a new york times
press briefing major carl hensley
suicide
ends up all the charges are eventually
dropped
against both barnes and franklin
colonel franklin eventually relieved
from his command
for throwing a vietnamese body out of uh
out of a helicopter
in vietnam and again this guy was the
most decorated
from what i could find in research's
most decorated officer from his west
point class
1950.
1991 by the way colonel franklin
convicted
and spent five years in prison for a
securities
scheme scam swindled about 100 people
out of millions of dollars
so there's like a you know you see these
questionable characters
characteristics so all the charges so
imagine this all the charges
against barnes and franklin get dropped
but herbert is not charged with making a
single
false statement so all these things that
he had said
he never gets charged for making a false
statement but the charges get dropped
he goes kind of public does a bunch of
interviews eventually
he's retired or he retires you know he's
done with the army
he gets eventually he gets interviewed
on
60 minutes by mike wallace
and this is freaking crazy so they have
and i've tried to find this haven't been
able to find it but i read about it
they have herbert getting interviewed by
mike wallace he kind of tells his story
and then out of the other room they
bring
major grimshaw who was part of the unit
who comes out and says yeah look i
i worked for herbert i know herbert i
respect herbert but what he said isn't
true
so so now who he's supposed to believe
so
herbert sues mike wallace in 60 minutes
for libel it's a 13-year court case
it's a 13-year court case
eventually gets all the way to supreme
court and herbert loses the case
herbert eventually made he became a
clinical psychologist and also a police
psychologist
dies of cancer june 7
2014.
just the the whole thing
is a travesty
and i guess the best thing we can do
is what can we learn from it
what can we learn from it i would say
the obvious lesson here
is put your ego aside and build
relationships with people
now you might say well these people are
doing wrong
okay so what what good do you do when
you just build form an antagonistic
relationship do you have
more influence over them or less
influence over them you have less
so if you can build a relationship with
people now listen this is again this is
so freaking hard this is what makes
leadership hard if these
if there's people that are doing things
that are immoral illegal unethical okay
what are you gonna do
you can do what herbert did stand up to
him and guess what he gets fired now he
has no influence over the situation
because if you think like you have to
stop that that's my moral obligation to
stop this
stuff from happening was did colonel
herbert stop it from happening
no instead he's gone he has no more
influence who took
who took over his battalion some yes man
one of colonel franklin's you know boys
that came in and started
towing the party line so
freaking disaster
it's a it's just a disaster you get you
get the high ground great you got the
high ground and then you
and then you uh uh look down on people
and you get an antagonistic relationship
with them
yeah and there's all that all the stuff
is documented you got to read the book
um and i'm sure we could have more
discussions maybe we will maybe we'll
bring some maybe we'll find somebody
that was there that knows more about it
i know look there's two sides to every
story too i mean you you were
you pointed out you know was were they
just trying to get the job done
is it was he exaggerating some of this
stuff i don't know
i don't know
my original take
was that this guy is like a hack
my original information that i got was
this guy was a hackworth type
individual
from that was from from colonel howe
his
herbert had worked for his grandfather
right so this is like the closest way to
get right now that we can go off of
i don't know i don't know
i know that leadership is a freaking
challenge
i know that
and this book proves it
[Applause]
i hate this feeling echo charles mm-hmm
the kind of empty feeling yeah sure
don't like it yeah and so i don't like
when i can't
really identify the truth i can't like
it
yeah and that's kind of why i
did think about that where thinking
about the other people's perspective you
know
and with that kind of you kind of think
like how did
let's say that the guy is like all wrong
like because in this phase
according to the story it kind of sounds
like they're almost like corrupt almost
where they're like hey who cares
you know kind of thing so it's like what
so what we just have a straight up
corrupt military is that what you're
saying like in that little that's that's
absolutely what he's saying yeah so
we know uncertain terms he's saying that
yeah but a normal
which is horrible for us to think that
this entire division or this entire
brigade at a minimum
was corrupt yeah and that's and that's
what i'm thinking
but the reality is like so
these aren't like bad people like most
people aren't just bad people who are
just like
destined for corruption or whatever it's
almost like you kind of got to consider
how did they get there
why is it like that it's not because
they're just these evil people who
finally got their
position of power and now can just
exploit weakness and
nothing like that but you take and you
put all these factors in place like the
fact that hey if you go do this tour
you're gonna get promoted you're going
to get more money you're you got to go
do this
and when you get over there well what's
the best way to get a good evaluation
you get a good evaluation by
doing what everyone else is doing late
you know you don't want to stick your
head up and
be the one that gets draws a bunch of
attention so if that's what we're doing
you know it's an expression that you use
you use this expression
that's what we're doing you know like
you'll say oh that's i thought that's
just what we were doing
yeah you use that expression sometimes
well
that's a normal thing for people to feel
look that's what we're doing okay
that's what everyone else is doing i'm
all okay
yeah if we're gonna let the vietnamese
kind of run
and do whatever they want if that's what
we're doing cool i don't want to be the
one that's
drawn a bunch of attention to myself it
ain't about me so i'm just going to
kind of sit back and let it happen yeah
so people get into that mode
and you lose vision here's the other
thing like how much confidence do you
have in yourself to say like hey
everyone here is wrong everyone here
that's letting this happen is wrong
you know how do you not feel like wait a
second there's you know a brigade of 5
000 people here and everyone's kind of
down with what's happening
and i'm the person that's not yeah
there's something wrong here
maybe it's wrong maybe there's something
wrong with me yeah
yeah and you get the momentum and the
inertia
of you get the inertia of hey
hey we're going to get a new battalion
commander soon enough don't worry about
this guy he'll be gone he's gonna only
gonna do be here for six months
what what are we trying to do make money
right we can run these little scams and
make some money
we we just wanna have the time passed so
i can move on
i can just be done with my job trust me
that's
that's a real thing even in today's
military like
have you ever heard the zero defect
zero defect model where it's like oh
yeah we're gonna promote someone that
has had no mistakes
so if you're over on deployment if
you're in iraq or you're in afghanistan
and you want to get promoted
and there's a mission to go do
and you get to decide whether you go do
that mission or not
do you think you should do it or not oh
yeah got it
yeah so if you don't basically if you
don't take that much action
you don't won't make that many mistakes
you can have the zero defect record you
have the zero defect record i went on
deployment
i did four missions they all went well
get a bronze star go home get a good
evaluation and we're good to go
or i'm gonna go over there i'm gonna do
a hundred missions
every single one of those missions is a
freaking challenge by the way
if you're doing four missions you can
kind of hand pick
you do 10 missions you do 20 missions
you're hand pick okay this one's
not bad not a bad area we've got really
good intel
looks good all right go we'll go ahead
and execute this one all right
if you're gonna do a hundred missions
you're going okay look this one's a
little bit more high risk but we're
gonna go it seems like it will make an
impact we'll go execute it
there's a tendency well not a tendency
there's a possibility that you say you
know what
look i i don't want to have anyone get
hurt i don't want to have any bad
you know i don't have any negatives on
my evaluation
i just want to get my job done and move
on you know i want to punch the ticket
so you end up doing 14 missions
and you did your job good for you and
now you get your ticket punched and you
go home and
everyone's good and by the way when you
get home guess what guess what everyone
says
hey he he did it he was a he was a
company commander
he was a battalion commander he did he's
a combat experienced veteran as he said
right so now you're kind of on a
pedestal a little bit yeah
even though you really don't know
anything so what i'm saying is the
system
even more so in vietnam was all set up
where hey get over there keep your mouth
shut
go with the flow fit in with the crew
and that's why hackworth had such a
freaking issue with it and so did
herbert
makes sense it's almost like they should
maybe
think about i'm saying this with
complete ignorance by the way but
they should change the little system to
be to have you know like diving ever
watch diving like
not on olympics or whatever diving right
like platform whatever
they have they have uh the score level
and the difficulty level exactly right
so you get a score for difficulty level
and if the difficulty level is low bruh
you're not going to get a high score you
know
yeah yeah it's true and that's fine
again the system is really it's very
easy for the system to fall
back into a zero defect mentality a
risk-averse mentality
because look i could go on deployment
tomorrow
and circumstances could be that there's
just not a lot going on
and so we did four missions not because
we weren't aggressive but just because
there wasn't that many missions to do
yeah and so i come back and you can't
look down on me you can't say well jocko
only did four missions
i did all the ones that i could i was
aggressive as i could possibly be we
only did four
yeah you go on deployment there's you
could do a hundred missions
but you only do four you come back sad
did as many as jocko we're good to go
and i i'm the overall leader i wasn't
there
so i'm looking at go hey echo did four
jacqua did four hey these guys are
equivalent we're good to go
move on meanwhile you were super risk
averse didn't take any chances really
didn't
impact the battlefield and you're gonna
get the same recognition so it's a very
difficult thing to do it's a very
difficult thing
and you can see you can see that vietnam
just got so wrapped up in this
this careerism of hey go do your time
keep your mouth shut get
you know go with the flow yeah and
that's that
what the what are the missions that
we're doing okay we're doing that kind
of mission cool
oh got it we got guys smoking pot no
one's really seems to notice that
okay well i guess we're smoking pot like
it's just
bad across the board and a lot of it has
to do with what is our mission
what is our mission why are we what what
means we want
yeah what means we want if you don't
even know what means you want how are
you gonna
you know if you went on a football field
and you didn't know what
how if you didn't know how to score a
goal what would you do
yeah what would you do you wouldn't be
able to do anything but as long as you
know hey here's where you're trying to
get to okay got it
give me that ball move it foot down the
field i'll i'm moving a yard down the
field i'm moving an inch down the field
you at least know which direction you're
moving it
if you get told hey go out on that field
no one tells you where the end zone is
right no one tells you so what are you
gonna do
so as a leader you got to take that into
account you got to make sure people know
what the mission is
you got to know what the strategy is
and you better know why you're going to
war and you better make that perfectly
clear when you're going
check empty feeling sorry
don't like it
all right so what else can we do
this is just a freaking well speaking of
empty feelings i have
one two three cans of empty two and a
half
so i'm going to take this opportunity to
tell our people what discipline goal
is all right i'm glad because i'm just i
had some too but i still feel empty
still so empty
it's all good uh well okay i won't start
with discipline go how about that we'll
just talk about jocko fuel in general
okay look we're on the path we're
learning stuff lessons hard and easy by
the way
obviously we're hoping man
yeah well you know how they say like
there's hard less like the hard lessons
are the ones that are learned like the
best
yes true he who suffers remembers
yeah there you go yeah so
boom so we're on the path right we're
looking for lessons we're learning from
lessons
learning from lessons from others that's
one of those efficiency things
yeah there's some great leadership
lessons in both these books that's for
sure
like some real like that thing about
planning if you if you let your team
come up with a plan they're invested
they have a
material interest in seeing the plan
succeed that right there is gold
read those books look you come away
feeling empty like i did let me fill in
that hole a little bit there i just did
i just filled in my own hole in my heart
from getting to the end of this book by
saying hey if you let your team come up
with a plan they have a material
interest in making the plan succeed
there you go i feel better already
me too so yes nonetheless we're on the
path
and through that path a lot of people
know about the path they don't walk the
path
i saw that meme today stuck in my head
but when we
when we do walk the path we may need
assistance
assistance through whether it be
mentorship guidance or
supplementation as far as
supplementation goes
we have jackal fuel so we got stuff for
our joints
we got stuff for protein we got stuff
for our brain
and we got stuff for immunity that's it
right shark
more or less we're not just getting
stronger with some milk yes that's the
approach that's the addition
oh yeah so and here's the thing i was
thinking about something else
i understand fully well here's the thing
here's the formula for getting strong
could you tell i was like not with you
yeah okay i'm just making sure
i'm very used to that dynamic
no usually i'm paying attention to what
you're saying well it depends on what
you mean by
usually but true you know anyway
the formula for getting strong that if
you sense that from me
it should be a non-verbal cue to talk
fast and kind of rap
yeah i thought that in the beginning but
now you know after a while yeah it's
just weird i don't care i'm very used to
you have no material interest in moving
this conversation along
which is fine i have a material interest
but it's very small
nonetheless okay the the material
formula
for being strong is three things
the correct exercise the correct rest in
recovery
and the correct fuel nutrition slash
fuel slash food
whatever yeah molk is part of that last
part the fuel
for getting strong it's insane so yeah
will make you strong as long as those
other two things are in place as well
sure anyway go to jackalful.com for all
these things
score score some supplementation for
this path that we are
walking not just knowing about you can
also get it at vitamin shop
you can also get it at wawa well you can
get the you can get the
discipline go drinks at wawa if you need
some energy
then you can go to wawa and get some and
also all these things which is kind of
cool
you're you're gonna want to get you want
to going to want to get them
and have them there when you need them
so you want to subscribe
and if you subscribe you get
free shipping and shipping can be
expensive
yeah you know it's yeah the i think
the the main benefit aside from the
discount for sure
um is you not having to think about it
you can think about other stuff no
that is a that is a definite benefit so
you're getting paid
basically to do something that's already
good for you
yeah you're right you're right rotation
of justice
so getting paid you know how they say a
penny saved is a penny
earned that's it right yep it's kind of
thing it's more of a framing thing okay
not to go too deep on framing please
don't but
if you just said you just said you're
getting paid to do something you're
healthy yeah
in a way right you are so if you
subscribe you're getting paid
to do something that's good for you yup
which is awesome yeah
check that out jackofield.com also we've
got a bunch of jiu jitsu stuff
if you are into jiu jitsu which you
should be
by all accounts you should be into jiu
jitsu go to
origin usa.com you can get jiu jitsu
stuff but
if you're let's say you haven't gotten
into jiu jitsu yet
you're going to but you still need
clothing for your body
you need jeans you need boots
you need t-shirts you need hoodies
sure you need hats well
there's a lot of benefits to hats yeah
you don't wear a hat
ever pretty much yeah anyways you can
get all that stuff
american-made made in america
made in america yeah origen usa.com
check it out also jocko has a store as
well four more of those shirts
and hats hoodies
shorts by the way shorts yes which i'm
wearing right now oh yeah deathcore
shorts
oh yeah yeah hardcore condo shirt that's
what i'm wearing today yeah
in honor of colonel david hackworth yes
sir
jack yep that's a good one uh yeah a lot
of stuff on there
um
i say it's to represent while we're on
the path that's what you say and that is
true every time
but there's a little bit more to it you
gotta find out for yourself also we have
a subscription situation on there too
for a little bit different types of
designs a little bit more
creative we enlisted john bozak who just
happens to be
maybe not happens to be because this is
all for a reason but
he is the illustrator for the way the
warrior kid
series and michael the dragons and mike
and the dragons
and some posters as well anyway this is
a good artist we enlisted him for some
of the designs on this subscription
shirt situation called the shirt locker
check anyway look into that if you like
that hey man get that
jackostore.com is where that's at we got
you can you can subscribe to this
podcast or the other podcast we got a
gut jocko unraveling
got a few new episodes of that out there
savage
grounded pondcast which we haven't done
in a while but warrior kid podcast we
got some new of those
new of those out if you want to you can
check all those out you can subscribe
you can also join us on the underground
the ug jocko ug jockwoodground.com
little alternative podcast we've been
doing some q a on there from people that
are
on jocko underground if you want to
subscribe to that
go to jacounderground.com it costs eight
dollars and 18 cents a month
if you can't afford that it's okay we
don't want to exclude
you because you're having a financial
rough spot
if you want to hear what we're talking
about you can go to
you can email assistants at
jockonunderground.com
yep also we have a youtube channel video
version of this podcast
also we have excerpts on there so you
can
be enlightened in the event of you
missing a certain concept or whatever
you know we try to post those regularly
so um so yeah you can you can check
those out
we're verified too by the way on youtube
proud of that are we
did you ever get that thing weren't you
supposed to get some thing
um like a plaque or something oh yeah
yeah the
play button or something i think that's
when you get to a certain amount of
subscribers i did not get it no
how many subscribers do you have to have
i for there's different plaques so i
think you get one
i don't i could be wrong like after ten
thousand or a hundred thousand
and then after a million if i'm not
mistaken and then after 10 million
subscribers
how many do we have uh we're we broke
the threshold of one million so
technically we should have two play
buttons somewhere
somewhere around here i don't know i
gotta double check you can play what
play button
or button icon trophies
anyway yeah we have a youtube channel
how about that okay accepted uh
psychological warfare we got an album
with tracks where i talk about
overcoming a moment of weakness we have
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer
putting out things that you can hang on
your wall that look cool books
bunch of books soldier which is the book
we covered today
the making of a soldier the book we
covered last podcast they're both by
anthony herbert
final spin it's a story that i wrote
might be a poem i'm not sure
you're gonna have to check it out
yourself it's available for pre-order
right now i'm sure the publisher is like
well there's probably only going to be
you know
we'll probably sell 50 of these so we'll
print 50.
if you don't pre-order don't be mad
pre-order so you can get that first that
dish leadership strategy and tactics
field manual the code
the evaluations of protocols disagree
with freedom field manual all the
warrior kid books miking the dragon
about face
extreme ownership of the dichotomy of
leadership i have a leadership
consultancy
it's called echelon front you can go to
echelonfront.com for
details if you want us to help inside
your organization we have online
training efonline.com
we've got a bunch of live events
including the muster 2021
go to extremeownership.com if you want
to come to one of those we've got ef
battlefield we've got
ftx if you want to help service members
active and retired service members their
families gold star families check out
mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my drawn out
orations
or you'll need more of echo's
questionable queries
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on the gram
and on facebook echoes at equity charles
i am at jocko willing and thanks to all
the people out there
in the service of our nation around the
world
and the just try and remember that the
enemies outside the wire
and try and keep the egos in check and
support each other
and to our police and law enforcement
firefighters and paramedics and emts and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and border patrol and secret service
and all first responders out there every
single day
thank you for doing what you do so that
we
can do what we do
and to everyone else
listen antagonistic
relationships do not help you in life
they don't help your mission
they don't help your team
if you don't agree with somebody on
something find something that you do
agree on
build bonds instead of breaking them
there is enough
in the world trying to rip us apart
fight that it's how
we all win in the end
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out